good morning and welcome to the face of
steel here in the magna science
adventure center in the former temple
steel works in rotherham we're here for
big ideas live a new format for sky news
that we hope will help us to explore big
issues big themes big ideas across the
agenda for the uk today on inking live
we're kicking off our coverage exploring
the challenges facing the economy as we
come out of the pandemic is boris
johnson's promise of a high wage high
skills economy deliverable and what
would it mean for business and are the
problems that we're seeing in the
country's supply chains a symptom of
short-term worker shortages or are we in
for a longer ride i'll be discussing
that with a panel taken from across
british business and i'll be introducing
them in a moment i'd also like to invite
you to ask questions or comments during
our day using the hashtag big ideas live
but first a feature of big ideas live
will be our sky news experts later we'll
hear from our economics and data editor
ed conway and my colleagues samantha
washington and trevor phillips but first
our business correspondent helen ann
smith is here to set the scene for our
discussion helena
thanks ian good morning everyone so
what's happened in the jobs market over
the last 18 months is perhaps one of the
greatest curiosities of this crisis
normally at times of recession we see
unemployment spiking we see vacancies
falling right down although unemployment
has been kept relatively in check
vacancies have actually behaved in
entirely the opposite way to what we
might have expected just this morning we
heard vacancies in september up record
highs again over 1.1 million and
although that might seem like good news
on the surface for workers the reality
might be a bit more nuanced and there's
big challenges for business about how to
realign to the new reality post pandemic
so first of all have a look at this what
we're plotting here is some of the the
key sectors that are driving that big
growth in vacancies up there at the top
transport and logistics we've heard so
much about it haven't we up 300 job
adverts there on what they were pre
pandemic but problems in other sectors
too manufacturing construction even
travel and tourism surprising perhaps
given the problems that that sector has
faced uh however that's not the case uh
in all sectors across the economy have a
look at this what we've plotted here is
some sectors where job vacancies are
actually down on what they were before
the pandemic some of this might not be
that surprising for example sales we
know retail
has had some problems but some sectors
here are a little bit surprising jobs
down in energy jobs down in legal
graduate jobs down as well and what's
essentially showing us is that there's a
realignment going to be happening in the
economy we know for example don't we
that there can be fewer jobs in places
for example like city centre sandwich
shops more jobs in places like
warehouses it may be a bit too soon to
see some of these things really playing
out in the data but some of the early
signs are certainly interesting now the
question for many of us is not just
where are the jobs but actually where
are the workers to fill all of these
vacancies and it's quite interesting
they might not necessarily always be in
the right places so what we've done here
is charting the number of unemployed and
furloughed people as of july against the
number of uh
regions of the country so essentially
the higher up they are on this graph the
more unemployed and furloughed people
there were as of july the further along
they are uh the greater growth in
vacancies that those sectors have seen
what this essentially shows is there's
different problems in different regions
london for example right up there at the
top absolutely the worst place to be in
the country right now if you're a worker
by far the highest number of people
potentially looking for work the fewest
vacancies over at the other side
different problems the northeast at the
largest number of vacancies there
yorkshire and the humber where we are
today higher vacancies and comparatively
fewer people looking for those jobs
so not only might the workers not be in
the right places but they might not also
be at the right skill level have a look
at this there is a slight correlation
between the number of vacancies in
certain sectors and the average earnings
in those sectors so over at this side
hospitality many more vacancies lower
pay on average over there on the other
end finance worth saying anecdotally
transport up there the big vacancies
driver anecdotally we do know that some
of the jobs that do exist are in those
lower paying driving jobs as opposed to
the managerial jobs as well and look as
we go forward over the coming years and
the coming decades there will be other
new challenges for businesses as well i
want to leave you with this one of the
challenges we may all face is automation
what this essentially shows is that
there is a direct correlation uh
anecdotally between
how likely a sector was to furlough its
workers in the recent crisis and how at
risk that sector might be from
automation so look up here at the top
food and tourism retail construction to
a degree as well highly likely to have
furloughed their workers during this
crisis much more at risk of automation
over here on the opposite end media
scientific i.t of course it won't go
unnoticed that these tend to be the
higher paying careers as well
potentially a slightly lower paying over
there so we big questions for businesses
not just about how these factors all
collide are we creating more vulnerable
group of workers going forward but
crucially also how business is going to
rise to this challenge and we'll be able
to find the workers that are needed
thank you ian thanks helen m
time now to introduce you to my panel of
experts on my far right is lord
billamoria the chairman of cobra founder
of vagobra and also president of the cbi
on my immediate right alvina malek she's
chief executive and co-founder of one
million mentors which pairs young people
with mentors in industry on my immediate
left is karl ennis he's chief executive
of siemens here in the uk and also ceo
of siemens smart infrastructure and on
my far left is clive chesser he's chief
executive of punch pubs and co and we
also have expertise in our audience
today from the regional business
community from local business owners and
hopefully one or two business leaders of
the future now before we get on to our
panel discussion we're going to touch on
a very live piece of news something
that's happened just around the corner
from here during the last 24 hours which
is that
the liberty still business has just been
told it's receiving a 50 million pounds
cash injection from its owner and i'm
very pleased to say we have chris
williamson in the audience he's branch
secretary of the community trade union
at liberty steel's rotherham plant chris
welcome to you you must be absolutely
delighted fantastic news
great relief
we've it's been arrowing for the last
few months but
it was
great
peace of mind to to get that funding in
place
i mean i mean obviously steel production
is an energy intensive business
energy bills the wholesale level and of
the retail level are going through the
roof right now do you worry that that
money is going to be consumed fairly
rapidly
if bullish is true to his word with his
rhetoric this morning hopefully we'll
get some movement
it is a deep concern we've had concerns
with it around energy for the last 30
years
around leveling up with the rest of
europe
but obviously this crisis has escalating
all right
chris great pleasure to have you here
with us today thanks very much for
joining us
on we go then and uh lord billy mora i'm
going to start with you we heard from
boris johnson last week he clearly wants
to turn the uk into a high-wage economy
but it seems to me i mean economic
orthodoxy is that high wages follow an
improvement in productivity boris
johnson it feels like he's trying to put
the car before the horse wants a high
wage
high skills
high investment
and high productivity
so you can say you want high wages but
unless you have all the other things
it's going to lead to inflation
so we've got to take this opportunity
now we all want those higher wages but
invest in skills now is the time those
graphs that we've just seen the
disintermediation that's going to take
place in the future regardless of the
pandemic regardless of the crisis we're
facing now that's staring us in the face
so the cbi we've calculated
over the next decade
businesses will have to invest 130
billion pounds in reskilling
so what the government's got to do is
right now things like the kickstart
scheme fantastic scheme to get young
people 16 to 24 year olds into work we
said please extend that beyond december
they've listened they're going to extend
it
things like the lifelong learning
account what a great initiative so
people at any age in their lives have
access to money to be able to retrain
the apprenticeship levy
good idea not working it needs to be far
more flexible so if you do all those
things you can reskill in our
universities the best in the world along
with america i'm proud to be chancellor
of the university of birmingham top 100
university in the world along with
siemens with carl and his team we've a
brand new ai enabled campus in dubai
state of the art 5000 students
that's global britain in action so we
can do it we're proving it let's invest
in it once you have that investment once
you have the skills
then you get the high wages and you have
the productivity then you get growth
that growth delivers jobs the jobs pay
the taxes the taxes pay for the public
services and pay down the debt the 400
billion
pounds that we're so grateful as
business the government has given that's
why unemployment the figures that have
come out today
at only four and a half percent before
the pandemic were the lowest in the
seventies at three and a half percent
people were expecting unemployment to go
up to ten percent if you remember off
the financial crisis
unemployment went up to over nine
percent and we
saved that now thanks to the government
help including the furlough scheme now
it's a very fragile recovery and this is
where government mustn't give up now
this is where government's going to work
with business to really support this
fragile recovery so we can have that
growth okay well kyle obviously you
invest an awful lot in uh skills and in
uh equipping the workforce for for the
modern economy
to what extent was that work blown off
course by the pandemic
so actually we were we were quite lucky
in that much of what we do was for
supporting national infrastructure
keeping the trains running
keeping the energy systems up and
running keeping medical equipment so
actually we we were able to employ
pretty much throughout many people
continuing to do what they were doing at
the at the face of work
and and a lot of our office people you
know adopted uh adopted technology and
were able to work from home so so i
think uh we uh we were able to survive
that skill topic if i just pick up on on
the other topic that karen completely
agree with all of that
and one of the ways you address
productivity is uh
is by deploying technology and i was
really interested in listening to uh it
was helena as in her introduction she
talks about risk of automation and
actually that for me speaks volumes
right there is no risk from alteration
there is a risk from not automating
because if we don't others will the
thing about the global britain is that
means we're on a global stage we have to
be competitive globally and i truly
believe if we don't adopt uh
automation new technologies at all in
all industrial areas then we will be
missing one of the biggest levers to
drive that productivity up that's just
the reality it is quite a terrifying
idea though i mean to a lot of people
isn't it the thought that they may lose
their job to ai to automation i mean how
how do you sell that to a skeptical
public
um well
i think as um
clyde was saying you know automation is
reality and we need to embrace it
um and i think there is a huge amount to
do in terms of investing in skills one
of the things lord bellamoria that we
need to do alongside all of the things
that you've outlined is actually invest
in our young people
and do it differently because if we keep
doing what we're doing we're going to
get the same result we're going to have
a disconnect that we have in the labor
market right now
what we do at one million mentors is we
provide opportunities for business to
connect with local young people the
talent the abundance of talent that does
exist in our communities and we need to
really escalate that and really
scale that up and put funding into those
connections
early on if we can get to young people
early on uh if we can introduce them to
the world of work world of work if we
can expose them to
opportunities guide them support them
pre-gcse
um to automated jobs to data you know
gathering be comfortable with technology
they are comfortable with digital tools
by the way young people aren't fearful
of automation but what they're fearful
of is not having the opportunities to go
into jobs which are highly skilled and
they're not prepared for that
whose role is that though is that the
role of local businesses or should the
schools be playing a greater role in
that time and do you think the schools
are doing enough right now on that front
good point and i i think schools are
doing brilliantly by the way um i do
um sort of resist the narrative that we
peddle that is all on schools to do
everything you know look after young
people's well-being educate them get
them jobs ready what we need is a really
scalable effort a collective effort like
we've never seen in the uk before which
is bringing business into schools and
supporting young people
alongside education by the way not as
part of the education alongside a
parallel
system whereby we are getting young
people job ready alongside being
educated and the way we think that can
be done is through personalized
one-to-one support businesses actively
engaging and supporting young people
through mentoring coaching and so forth
okay clive i'm conscious we haven't let
you have a chance to speak yet but
before we do just want to go back to
chris in the audience if you could share
some of your experiences in terms of
training and skilling what's it what's
it like at liberty
it's basically on the job training
obviously we have apprenticeships for
engineering side of things but
the production side is more on the job
training
and
it is a
it's a good level and
we
thought it
made to ensure that they're competent
before
we put them obviously into such a
dangerous environment of course
thank you well clive obviously
your business employs an awful lot of
young people
when they join you
are they fit for the world of work i
remember one of this country's
best-known chief executives more than a
decade ago massive employer but not say
who it was um and i remember him saying
to me when we get people out of school
or college the first thing we have to do
is teach them how to read and write and
count because a lot of them can't do it
properly are things better than that
that was a decade ago i was told that
yeah things are things are definitely
better than that i mean pub pubs so we
run um at punch pubs and co we run 1300
community pubs right across the uk so
from the isle of skye to the isle of
silly actually
and so our pubs provide a great entry
point for young people into the world of
work
and it's it's it's about personality as
much as about technical skills uh and
our publicans do a fantastic job i think
at developing people into the world of
work as an industry we need to do better
at making sure that people see it as a
career opportunity and a longer term
career opportunity as opposed to a sort
of transient first job um but uh you
know we we see people coming to our
industry all the time from a very young
age and they can rise as stars and be
managing their own businesses actually
within two or three years it's quite
unusual so you know it's important for
us uh i think to uh to make sure that uh
you know we we continue to be able to
provide those opportunities uh and at
the minute you know things are obviously
very difficult we've got pubs that are
struggling to find uh find the staff
that we need and if we're struggling to
find them then i think everybody must be
really key point you've touched on their
labour shortages right now i mean
obviously the hospitality industry had a
terrible time during the the pandemic
lots of businesses went under where do
you go from here are you are you seeing
signs of optimism now despite these
labor shortages
yeah it's really it's really
complicated actually i mean it's
confusing and it's not it's not a
consistent picture across the country so
there are you know they're very
different stories actually so pubs down
in the southwest in sort of domestic
tourism land have had you know
phenomenal trade through the summer but
there are a number of businesses that
have had a really much slower recovery
and a much tougher time um generally
speaking i think we're you know we're
quite optimistic about the rebound that
we've seen in consumer demand
the challenge is in satisfying that
demand and the complexity of delivering
um through the supply chain through
labor
and it's very frustrating actually uh
that uh you know in some areas um you
know we're not able to keep up with that
and that's a very unusual place for us
to be so
fragile complicated but actually the
underlying position i think is one of
optimism and you know we've seen the
love of people coming back to
hospitality and community pubs in
particular being really strong so that
we know that in the long term if we can
get all the pieces right along the way
actually i think that you know the
long-term rebound can look strong
but obviously we've got inflation coming
through the pipeline are you going to be
able to absorb is that hits going to be
on your margins are you going to be able
to pass that on to customers well a huge
amount of costs are being absorbed right
now uh in increasingly day by day that's
getting more difficult um and nobody
wants to see prices just being passed on
to customers uh there's you know clearly
uh you know this price elasticity and
and we've got to deliver great value and
quality uh to our to our guests in our
pubs so uh the truth is that costs are
being absorbed and margins are getting
squeezed um and we need to continue to
get the support that we've had from
government through the through the covid
pandemic
beyond the current uh measures that are
in place in the longer term and to have
a real transition plan you know i
thought that the the the tone of the um
of the the the conference last week in
the prime minister's speech felt quite
celebratory as if covet is now in the
rear view mirror and it's been gone
that's not how it feels um kate nichols
who runs uk hospitality i think said uh
that the the industry has got some
symptoms of long covid that's quite a
good analogy because fundamentally we're
back up and running we're out of
hospital we're healthy we're open but
we've still got some symptoms that are
very real
and we need the support from the
government for our sector in particular
extending the vat cut is really
important because that does help to
prevent price increases being passed
straight through to the consumer
but also help with um with
beer duty in particular for the
hospitality sector and the on trade
sector and then the business rates
reform which is promised
but we've got a long way until that
comes in we've got some support in place
now until march next year and that needs
to be extended as well because that is a
very significant cost for businesses
like ours that are bricks and mortar on
the high street in towns across the
country so we need a strong transition
plan from the government to enable us to
get through these symptoms of
long-covered and then i think the future
can look can look bright
obviously low pay is a real issue
throughout the economy the prime
minister's uh made it very clear it's on
his agenda and we have a question to
that and from tiffany jackson
in the audience tiffany would you like
to
make yourself
known to us
my question is how important is it for
young people to have a voice in the
dialogue around the future of work and
learning and how can businesses help
facilitate and support this
thanks tiffany for those did you catch
that the question was how important is
it for young people to have a voice in
the dialogue around the future of work i
think yeah you're very well placed
brilliant
absolutely integral for young people to
be part of that dialogue what we know is
we have
one of the most diverse most educated uh
labor coming through young people coming
through into the economy and they're
very clear about what they want they're
very clear you know they are
mobile they're resilient they're values
driven they want businesses that are
supporting their well-being they want
ethical leadership they want um you know
inclusive
ideal
is where they have good wages where
there is career progression and where
there are good conditions you know um
and i think they have to be part of the
solution but for me the onus really is
on
the employers um you know to be able to
change their culture change their
practices change their
recruitment and hiring
practices in order to attract this
phenomenal talent that is in the uk
karen did you want to jump in yes and
it's such an important point because if
you think about this crisis
lots of us we've all suffered but young
people have suffered so much whether
it's missing out on school whether it's
missing out on university
it's been really really difficult
and i think we've got to do everything
we can to support young people and as
alvina said that what matters all the
surveys show the two things that are
more important to young people
than other things one they passionately
care about climate change sustainability
diverse biodiversity the environment
really matters the next thing is
diversity and inclusion
it really matters i'm the first ethnic
minority
cbi president in its history
and i've launched an initiative called
change the race ratio
to champion ethnic minority
participation across all business and
lots of big companies have signed up to
it microsoft ey aviva siemens everyone's
it's it's a fantastic initiative that's
the sort of thing we've got to do and
the other thing is
at schools
we've got to get businesses into schools
if
survey after service shown if you if if
children are exposed to business through
visits from business leaders into
schools they are so much more likely to
be employable
secondly field visits if children go and
visit businesses visit factories it has
a huge impact on i can still remember my
field visits from 11 years old when i
went to a pencil factory
it has a big impact so i think we've got
to put young people make a very
important priority all right carl i'm
going to come to you in a second but we
have a question on the related uh issue
here from bob jeffrey who's in the
audience bob if you'd like to uh there
he is
hi i'm bob jeffrey i'm the uh president
of sheffield tuc the local trades
council of the neighboring trades
council
and given the lack of effective
employment protections here in the uk we
relatively come near the bottom of the
league of oecd countries for for
employment protection how are we how
important are trade unions in terms of
driving up the quality of jobs
thanks bob who wants to take that how
important trade unions in driving the
quality of jobs
uh well i'll have a i'll have a crack at
it um um i i would say uh that listen
the the the any mechanism that that
gives the voice of the employee to to
the senior levels of the organization
has to be has to be an important element
uh in siemens we have parts of our
organization where they are uh trade
unions are recognized in others where
where they're not uh and and actually
it's horses for courses so i don't think
it's the only route for communication
back to alvina's point and then the
question earlier actually i find the
interaction within with the employees
individually on uh far more uh far more
useful uh than perhaps you know uh
conglomerated responses so so i would
say yeah we need to listen to our
employees i mean we are listening to our
employees uh and and on that topic of of
training in the voice of individuals i'm
i'm
lucky enough to have two children a 16
year old daughter and a 19 year old son
who have lived their all levels and a
levels through the pandemic and
and and actually you know that's why i
agree that it is a group of people who
have hugely suffered actually
we've embraced technology we've been
doing uh work experience uh remotely and
actually there's quite an interesting
challenge for us as an engineering
organisation we often find it difficult
to get to ethnic minorities to get to
agenda balance correctly actually in our
our
um
online uh workplace experience uh we
ended up having 50 female
attendees and more than 50 in black and
minor
minority ethnics so actually those new
ways of engaging with people have also
been something that we're going to
continue to doing post-pandemic so
there's lots of pain in the pandemic but
there's also lots of things we've
learned that have been useful and we
should be you know careful not to throw
the baby out with the bath water and
make sure we embrace and keep embracing
those new ways of of engaging
karen made the point about getting
schools into business
how have you been able to market
engineering and science careers as sexy
to school kids
that's a trick isn't it uh although i i
have to say i'm you know
we might talk about uh karen mentioned
about decarbonization the biggest global
challenge for the world uh and who's
going to fix it right probably an
engineer and a scientist are going to be
at the heart of it that makes that's
pretty sexy so we we were involved uh in
in
in the ventilator challenge so we were
involved in a number of uh of other
engineering organizations when the call
came that there was a concern we weren't
going to have enough ventilators we were
making 20 a week we needed to make 2 000
a week
and within the space of four weeks we
had we'd created a production line we'd
use digital technology to do it we'd
used the knowledge of of the experts
we've taken management and left
management to them at the door to to
avoid egos and actually we we found a
solution and it was brilliant and you
know again i look unfortunately i have
not been able to convince either of my
children to go into engineering but
that's because i'm a rubbish salesman
and uh however that that i think they
see now starting to see now the value of
science and engineering
but of course we need to keep on about
it it's easily forgotten and and yes we
have them uh uh young young people
coming into our organization we also
have a lot of our employees who are
engaged with with young people i sit on
the engineering uk uh
board which is a group of businesses uh
supporting key stage two and three so
very early on in getting over this idea
that an engineer is somebody who comes
home with with grit under the
fingernails now i do that sometimes
because i like uh
tinkering in my garage but actually
generally there's lots more that we can
do and actually if we're really at the
cornerstone of fixing the the the future
of the planet i think that's quite a
sexy place to be
is it time that we started to
abandon this target of half the
country's college leavers going to
university and push more people into
apprenticeships
um only if the apprenticeships work
um and i think there's a lot more work
we need to do with apprenticeships but
there are lots of different
opportunities and i think picking up
what carl was saying um young people are
i mean they have had as you said a
little bit more they have been
uncertainty around gcse and a levels my
children went through the same um
experience and it was as hard for them
as it was for as a parent but young
people now as the lock down eases are
feeling a lot more positive which is
really interesting you know they're
beginning to socialize a bit more but
they're also being able to pick up
opportunities that they wouldn't have
had pre-pandemics so the young people
that we work with over 3 000
some of them are now applying for roles
because of remote working
they live in the north but they're
applying for roles in the south and i
think that's fantastic and i think
that's really
positive in terms of geographical
barriers not being as
important as they were pre-pandemic and
we need to keep that going i think young
people
are beginning to look at opportunities
beyond university and i do think
it is important that they do that
because we know what the skills shortage
is we know what future jobs looks like
and therefore it's incumbent on all of
us here in this room and across the
country to identify and support young
people from an early age pre-gcse
to
find the right career path for them
which doesn't mean university for some
are you recognizing that clive
totally totally come to hospitality
we need you we want you and uh and it's
a great career path for young people and
then i guess my request to the
government in terms of working with us
to help unlock some of the uh some of
the blockages uh is to think about um
the apprentice scheme think about the
kickstart scheme through the eyes of
small business owners so our pubs are
run by independent operators
and you know we regularly look at these
schemes and say well why can we not get
more traction because they're overly
bureaucratic and they're complicated and
we need to make everything flow as
simply and and smoothly as possible uh
and thinking about each individual small
business having to undertake the the the
workload to make these schemes work
which everybody wants did you want to
jump in just on on the apprentice topic
and this idea that apprenticeship is a
second class uh you know route into i'm
i'm slightly biased here i left school
at 16 and did an apprenticeship i don't
think i did too bad for myself the
process that followed so i think it
really is it's a great grounding and so
you know somebody was talking uh earlier
on about uh on the job training actually
on the job training is some of the best
training that we are actually able to
give our youngsters so these are not
negative things these are really
positive things
and and you started as an apprentice and
you can go far beyond that well i mean
it's so important i i qualified as a
chartered accountant
and you qualify while you're working and
works a term called ui and you know you
on it's on the job training and you get
a professional qualification i want to
pick up on bob's point so important
throughout this pandemic
it's my father remember said that the
true test of leadership is not
in the good times it's in times of
adversity and this is when business
leadership has been really tested and
how businesses have treated their
employees will be remembered will be
remembered by the employees the ones who
are treated badly the ones who are
treated well and companies having a
purpose is so important
and a company with purpose will work
very closely with everybody with
the whole family that makes up the
employees the customers the suppliers
the advisors they're partners of the
same family if you have that attitude it
works and what is absolutely awful
is if you have bullying of any or any
sort going on
and to your point trade unions
there was a photograph taken on the
steps of number 11 with rishi sunak the
director general of cbi
and the head of the tuc
side by side government unions business
working together and we helped work the
furlough scheme so much through this
pandemic we've worked closely together
and that's how it should be
we've got a question from the audience
matt in the audience i think wants to
ask about
matt in the audience wants to ask about
incentives
oh it's nat sorry not matt
not there you are
um so we saw the data earlier on and it
was really interesting but i think that
we can all agree that education and
health should be considered as important
as our finance sectors and and we we
shouldn't really accept lower salaries
in this areas as a result of that so
surely recruitment retention and quality
could all be improved as a result of uh
increased investment in these areas but
not just from a training and
pre-employment perspective but following
on we need to keep people in these jobs
and then ultimately they act as role
models for the young people coming
through we don't have to spend as much
time trying to recruit at an early age
because we've got the role models later
on to encourage them to come through
who wants to take that clive that sounds
like one for you well i'd say the same
is true in hospitality actually so uh
you know our our challenge is to is to
is to keep people and develop and
develop
their time and hospitality into a
long-term career
and we have to work harder as a sector i
i think in in achieving that because it
is a meritocracy and it's a you know
it's a flat structure and people can
move through it very fast so
uh i totally agree you know getting
people in an entry level and then
enabling them to grow and developing
their skills on the job and it is very
much on the job training um and you know
we have a good pathway to do that uh we
need to do it better
i think you're absolutely spot on that
lifelong learning is incredibly
important now it's not just about
entry level it's throughout because we
know the labor force that's coming
through is much more mobile if we're not
going to give them the experience if
we're not going to look after them we're
not going to
ensure that their well-being is priority
then they will leave and we'll be you
know the investment is gone um but the
point you're making around role models
is absolutely important um relatable
people who can support young people in
places like rotherham you know where
there is generations of worklessness
and say to them look we made it you can
make it this is the way we will support
you and invest and tell those young
people that you are important is it is
beyond i think that's a single thing
that will
um address some of the complexities in
our labor market mentoring is key
i think the the data that you shared at
the beginning demonstrates like doesn't
it we've got role models in in tech and
these you know upcoming innovative
careers where individuals are valued as
employees and we're seeing high
vacancies and not as much interest in
some of the other areas like hospitality
and leisure where we haven't got the
same amount of role models active that's
right
well i think i think the point you're
making is that teachers people in
education
nurses
do they get paid for what they're really
worth
i believe they get way
way underpaid i mean do you remember the
teachers who changed your life
they they change our lives they make our
lives they save our lives you know so i
believe that we've got to really
encourage people to go into those
careers and you follow your passion not
your pension and what you really love
doing i mean solicitors now american
firms in the city are paying newly
qualified solicitors i heard yesterday
the extreme is 250 000 pounds to
somebody in their early 20s 125 000
pounds
that's the disparity that exists
yes i often wonder where where i went
wrong really and obviously in a career
in the law but i mean we're all agreed
that education is is very very important
we've got a budget coming up on the 27th
of this month we've had the institute
for fiscal studies yesterday their green
budget and they're making the point that
essentially spending on the nhs is
crowding out all other areas of public
spending those unprotected areas
of government local government education
defense transport all of those are going
to be squeezed all the money is going to
the nhs are you comfortable with the way
that
the nhs almost appears to be a cuckoo in
the nest and that all other public
spending's been crowded out
historically if you look at overall um
public spending to gdp
we've tried to get to around 40 percent
of of gdp
now if you look at the figures during
the pandemic i mean it's gone way over
that then you say that's in a time of
crisis then you say you need more
spending on health which we do then you
say you need more one of the things a
pandemic has really highlighted is
social care that it's been a neglected
sector i was shocked in april last year
went on a major television program and
the news broke back that day
that patients were being sent back from
hospitals into care homes without being
tested i said how could this be
happening and then it highlighted how
social care has been neglected so it
needs more funding no question about
that
so how do we now looking forward give
the spending is required but also
increase the tax take to be able to
spend to spend it to pay for it but also
increase the growth
because if you have a an austerity
high tax
that will stifle growth that will stifle
domestic investment that will stifle
inward investment with the second
largest recipient of inward investment
in the world if you put up taxes too
much if just if your spending is out of
kill you will not attract that
investment so we've got to be very
careful going ahead there's no question
the investment is required clive have
you run the numbers how much is this
rise in national insurance next year
going to cost you
painful
but it's not but it's it's not just
national insurance it's it's the cost
increases we're seeing on virtually
every line of the p l so it's the
cumulative impact of that but in terms
of the government investment and where
the money goes i would encourage the
government to think of it as investment
and not as a cost so particularly you
know
obviously you know my world is embedded
in pubs and hospitality we it by
supporting our sector
that is supporting the regeneration of
jobs and local economies in in hundreds
thousands of every town and village
actually across the uk we are the yeah
we are a good conduit to reinvesting in
local communities creating jobs
investing capital into uh into our
buildings into new businesses
and investing in improving our
businesses and we're still at that stage
at this transition stage where you know
we need that support to be able to help
to stimulate the government uh the
economy recovery and the leveling up
agenda uh we're you know a brilliant uh
route to achieve that uh and all of the
costs that you know we are incurring at
the minute are just getting in the way
of that car you must be seeing that as
well absolutely i mean the the cost
increases have have been uh you know
quite quite brutal for for all for all
sectors i think it is a difficult
challenge for the government as to
whether spend the money i always think
of it they've they've got to spend it
where they think they're going to get
the best value from it you know and and
so i think that that's that has to be
focused you know if you do things
sector-wide you end up spreading lots of
money and i appreciate as government
it's very difficult to be to be narrow
but uh but i think if we could be a
little bit more intelligent in our
decision making and make sure that that
recognizing we have got to pay down the
debt that we've we've increased you know
in as a part of kovid that was that's
not a freebie somebody's got to pay for
that well we're never going to pay down
the debt
we'll eventually pay it down but uh um
you know we we
won't pay it down completely you're
right but but to pre-pandemic levels is
where we should be aiming for um however
i also do think you have to be very
careful that you know it's about growth
it really is about growth and where and
we need growth in all sectors not in in
one or other sector so this isn't about
just engineering or or just hospitality
or or health care it's it's everywhere
and that's a really difficult challenge
to to to balance and that's back to this
you know you you attract investment by
being productive
well i mean you as a business you're
going to be hit in a few years time by a
big jump in corporation tax absolutely
are you going to get value for money
from the government for that for all
these extra taxes that you're going to
be paying yeah great great question it's
very difficult to tie those taxes into
real real value for money so those are
coming i mean the only other thing i
would say is there are some positive
things that have been done the super
deduction which is a way to get large
businesses uh to invest in technology to
drive productivity and i think that's a
that was a great lever in last year's
budget but it's too short-term because
it actually that will fall out just as
the corporate
to go corporation taxis going up so i
think there are things that the the
government could do rather than hitting
people with a stick but actually giving
them a carrot to invest can often can
often get the same if not a better
outcome just quickly to add to that it's
a very important point you made the
super deduction to encourage investment
government can do a lot to incentivize
that problem is that's going to be taken
away at the same time the corporation
tax is going up so our message governors
keep that in incentive going but we as a
country
under invest in research and development
and innovation we spend 1.7 of gdp
america germany is 2.8 percent
israel 4
if we spend that extra 1 that's an extra
20 billion pounds a year if you imagine
the productivity increase the growth the
employment that's generated out of that
increased investment that's what we
should be investing absolutely and there
is some rumor that that target for
for r d will actually push out we spend
more than those figures in r d but we
are a technology an engineering company
we have to invest i think again it's
it's when you're making those tough
decisions be careful not to to just look
at the here and now and do have one eye
to the long term and i know that's a
really difficult balance and we all do
that in our business life and the
government has to do it at the country
level but
fundamentally it's easy to to have a
short win it's easy to make everybody
happy now the goal is not about
everybody happy now it's about that
long-term journey
we have a question from phil miller in
the audience is phil here
good to see you sir
yeah my question is that obviously since
kobe did everything it's pretty tight
for money in businesses and obviously
we're looking to get to net zero
what are the chances of the government
giving a low-cost
loan
to help the green infrastructure
thanks phil did everyone catch that
who wants to have a tackle at that of
the champion at the bitcoin i'll have a
bit of a go of it of it
and i think that well low-cost loans i
think what government first of all that
the challenge for decarbonisation for
this country is huge we you know we
people just don't get the scale of the
challenge in front of us we did a piece
of work to just look at the north west
and said if you were going to get that
to net zero by 2050 you're going to have
to invest 200 billion pounds okay that's
just one area of of the the country now
on a positive note that 200 billion is
not necessarily have to be public when
in fact it shouldn't be
and the model we need to look at is is
offshore wind um where the government
said long-term policy it set some seed
funding so it did provide some incentive
for people to invest and that created a
market that then attracted huge amounts
of investment both both uk and
international investment and actually
then we saw the price of of offshore
energy drops so there's a really good
model so we know how to make
decarbonization work i would just caveat
with a couple of things and said uh i
think as a country we've done a lot so i
get the opportunity to speak to my
colleagues across the world and i do
think we are leading the the charge on
on decarbonisation we don't always get
it right but i think we're leading the
charge
what we've done so far is about fixing
the big centralized uh stuff like power
generation i think the next things
around heat uh
homes buildings and transport are all
local topics and i think that is another
challenge and i know your panel this
afternoon is around leveling up but as a
lad from rochdale with most of our
facilities based in the north of england
i'm pretty pretty passionate about this
topic and i think there is a a role for
for the regions to take in in leveling
up and i've seen that in in some regions
like manchester and liverpool where
where they've
coordinated themselves and now the
government need to
to devolve more powers to those there
are some regions that are not quite so
well coordinated right so so there are
some regions that need to organize
themselves to get the benefit from it i
think if they are able to do that that
the transport challenge the heat
challenge their local challenges they
will generate local jobs for local
people at very good levels and actually
if we create markets there is more than
enough investment globally to actually
to do that the government need to create
stable policy
and to provide a little bit of seed
funding to get the whole thing started
thanks scott wait it's taken us 40
minutes but we finally have the
expression leveling up
bingo
someone will have a card out there
what do you understand by the term
leveling up is it just a bit of
empty rhetoric or is there actually
something behind it i think it's
absolutely essential i think we need to
be in a position where every person in
this country has the opportunity to
access the opportunity
jobs that are available across the uk
so it needs to be more than just talk it
needs to be action i think we are in a
position now
to rethink and reset you know the
pandemic has provided us opportunities
to recalibrate and to think through
how do we actually make things happen
like leveling up how do we get
um every young person in this country
into jobs that are available
and there are many jobs are available
and to do that it cannot be the
situation now
that the only way young people get jobs
is through personal connections it has
to be open to every single person and
the way to do that is what we've been
talking about today is about ensuring
that business
gets into schools alongside education
and exposes these young people to work
becomes the trusted adult that
identifies career opportunities
and actually i talk about young people
because that's my job but actually
there's a huge amount to do with the
over 50s as well you know mentoring
should be
a sort of tool to enable um labor market
to become much more fluid um and i think
leveling up is essential really really
good point there about older workers i
mean we keep being told by the
government that it's desirable for some
people to change careers mid-track but i
mean do you see it in your business
clive do you see
people over the age of 50 saying i've
had a
you know
a damascene moment and i want to go and
pull pints
coming in to the industry at an older
age um
not so much um probably something we
should be trying to attract actually uh
we don't care how old people are or
where they come from we want them to
have a personality and a great work
ethic and a passion for hospitality um
so
not particularly you know our um our
issue is you know is is that we over
index on on younger workers which is
great um we under index on older workers
so you know that's a good idea in a
campaign for uh people of my age and
older to come into hospitality if this
goes badly i might end up doing it again
i used to do this paul points to the red
line in whittington in manchester
look we talked we talked about
reskilling we talked about uh some of
the supply chain issues that you're
facing labor shortages the the elephant
in the room really is the economic
backdrop
potentially a rise in interest rates
around the table the money markets are
pricing him at least a couple by this
time next year
how much of a threat is that going to be
to this nascent recovery that we're
seeing
so just before i answer that if i may
just pick up a comment very important
point about this leveling up in arduino
prosperity throughout all the regions
and it should not be at the expense of
london it should be london prospering
benefits the whole country but it's
london and the rest of the country
and when it comes to climate change
heat is such a big issue that we we
don't address i chaired the heat
commission one third of greenhouse gas
emissions comes from heat
half of that comes from buildings and
out of the 29 homes in this country 29
million homes in this country only one
million are up to the standard way to
reach net zero by 2050 that means
upgrading 28 million homes the cost of
that the jobs that are created to scale
and implement that
the body that needs to be created we've
got the national center for
decarbonization of heat in the west
midlands that could do this throughout
the country it's a huge challenge and
we've got to face it we've got cop 26
the un climate change conference this is
where britain can show global leadership
on the stage well we're all about big
ideas and i think you've just come up
with a big idea for jobs there
and if i can just add you know what
gives me confidence that how we'll get
there and how it will be funded
uh i have no idea but what i do know is
that is that i have absolute confidence
and excitement about the younger age
group our consumer of tomorrow or today
will demand these things so that they
won't be coming into our pubs if they
don't meet you know the the the criteria
and you know
and that actually gives me the
confidence uh from an employee workforce
point of view they want to work for us
our consumers won't want to be coming in
so these changes absolutely um will come
through we have to find a way of
funding them uh effectively
back to this point of the interest rate
so guys how are you going to trade
through this i mean i think from from my
perspective the interest rate is perhaps
not a direct uh uh challenge but it
impacts markets and it impacts
confidence and anything that does that
and perhaps uh karen mentioned before
just how
how fragile the recovery is and and i
will say it really is fragile it's it's
we're on the knife edge i'm all i'm ever
the optimist right i'm convinced we will
come out well but but i have to say that
any dints to to to uh the confidence of
of of uh public investing uh on on on
hospitality markets for example or major
investments in national infrastructure
anything that stops people doing that
and we may find ourselves uh the the the
the positive you know it was mentioned
uh the other day that our recovery is
the highest
in performance of our uh uh economy
since the recovery of covid is the
highest in g7 that's great that's a
great position but we need to keep it
there and anything that dense confidence
is is a worry to answer your question as
well
the
chief
executive
chief economist the imf in may when i
checked the b7 before the g7
she said you're going to have a great
recovery in this country you've invested
400 billion pounds to save your economy
you've got a vaccination program that's
world leading you'll have a v-shaped
bounce back recovery what's happened
since may and now
all these challenges got taxes going up
you've got the energy crisis you've got
the fuel crisis you've got inflation now
the inflation's meant to be temporary
but now there's talk that this inflation
which is meant to be four and a half
percent might go up to six percent seven
percent if that inflation persists
the government will have the bankruptcy
had no option but to put up interest
rates absolutely you put up interest
rates by one percent
the cost of government borrowing goes up
by 26 billion pounds mortgages go up
consumers suffer businesses suffer
investment is effective so this is a
very serious situation we've got to
watch it very carefully that's why i
keep saying to the government work with
business we've got to try and work
through this and generate that growth
generate the jobs so we can get through
this together and have a resilient
sustainable recovery i mean clive you're
in a consumer-facing business
next year april next year everyone in
this room possibly everyone on paye they
can have the experience of looking at
their salary notification and it'll be
less than the month before that's a big
thing that hasn't happened to many
people in this country for decades it's
going to have a real impact on consumer
psychology isn't it yeah and people talk
about consumer confidence being
important in a recovery actually you
know we live in the here and now i think
you know pubs are a great litmus
test actually for the how the country
has performed that week
uh and the disposable income that people
have in their pockets a lot of that goes
on there you know leisure spend and for
a lot of people in their community pub
so it's it's a very real threat to us
it's something that you know
is you know is very much in the here and
now not just for next for for next march
and april um and you know we are
absorbing costs left right and center
and so uh so our all our businesses and
our customers
um you know it's very real and that's
why we need the support to have a longer
term
transition plan to prevent such a lumpy
recovery and to try and build a smooth
platform from from where we are now
yeah tough time for you guys really uh
i feel for you i really do
we're about to come uh to the conclusion
of this but uh we've had a lot of
interesting uh points made by a panelist
and certainly one big idea from uh karen
villamori there for which uh many thanks
we're now gonna hear a little from our
data and economics editor ed conway
about what he's going to be talking
about in just a few moments
hi ian uh and hello everyone um yeah i i
mean such an interesting panel so many
different issues that are kind of vying
with each other for our attention at the
moment and hopefully i'll be taking some
of those issues and trying to make a bit
of sense to them i mean often when it
comes to you know what we do in our
coverage we're trying to explain and
simplify what's happening right now but
it's hard to think of another time when
there's been so much complexity and so
many different dynamics happening
beneath the surface all of which we're
starting to notice now uh whether it's
us just kind of watching it or indeed
businesses and executives taking part in
it so we'll be going through some of
that we're looking through some of the
numbers i mean it's very difficult for
me to be in front of a big screen like
this without having a chart behind me so
we'll have lots of charts and lots of
data but also try to kind of underline
some of the points you've been hearing
about and some of the stuff we'll be
hearing about later on today because
we've got some other really interesting
guests yet to come in so so lots more
interesting stuff yeah it's coming ed
what do you make of what you've thought
about the potential for an interest rate
right i mean i i
it's it's really interesting
the extent to which central banks you
know every time there's been an
inflation scare going back to the 1970s
or indeed before that
basically they have missed it you know
conventional economics has failed to
forecast inflation ahead of it actually
happening and if you look back at what
the bank of england was saying only
earlier on this year inflation was going
to go to maybe two percent it went way
above that it's gonna go to three
percent it went way above that as maybe
now they think it's gonna go to four
percent so i mean if you read between
the lines you know they've they've been
behind the curve a lot you know
previously it's not impossible that they
might be behind the curve this time
around as well so it's not impossible no
you know markets aren't quite there yet
but you know there could even be one
this year we'll have to see i'm worth
pointing out a lot of central banks
around the world are already raising the
interest rates poland just the other day
new zealand sri lanka i think the
russians have raised interest rates five
times this year so it's happening in
some parts of the world it's happening
and and you know when you look at
inflation it's clear that prices are
rising we're seeing this coming through
the pipeline right now i mean you know
i'm sure many in the audience and here
on the panel will have seen that as well
and just trying to work out i don't want
to give away all of what i'm talking
about later but trying to work out
what's coming down the path towards us
is i think going to be one of the
biggest challenges that you know we uh
within journalism but also within
business are going to face in the coming
years because you know this is uh going
to be a volatile world we're living in
at the moment ed thanks for that quick
word of thanks to our panelists clive
marvina karen thank you all very much
for your contributions that is it from
this special ian king live part of the
big ideas live today here on sky news
you can follow ed's presentation next by
going to our live stream online and
we'll be back on sky news at 11 30 when
the former governor of the bank of
england mark carney will be speaking to
us about the challenges facing the world
and uk economies and the promise of cop
26 but that is it for now thank you very
much indeed
[Music]
the economy and the workforce have got
some rebuilding to do lots of jobs need
new staff and lots of staff want new
jobs in the construction industry
vacancies are up and so too is student
optimism
a solid start for those still in
training
quite a well-needed
job in the future so that's why i
thought i'd go through with it because
it's quite a lot of work to be done in
brooklyn everyone needs a brick player
every now and then so hopefully i can
find an apprenticeship get some my
on-site experience probably do a few
years under like a business
and then eventually probably start my
own business up
the principal's worked here nearly 20
years he says job openings now are the
best he's ever seen not just in the
sector but in the yorkshire region too
the industry is buzzing
there's major skills gaps in the
industry in construction in particular
at the moment and that's not just
locally but it's also regionally and
nationally as well it's really a buyer's
market for our students really and an
opportunity for our employers to what i
would say is fishing our pond really
down the m1 in rotherham this hasn't
always been the case a town with a proud
industrial past it's still a relief here
that liberty steel jobs will stay
job openings not the answer to
everything
on the surface record job vacancies
sounds like good news for workers in
places like this but the reality is a
little more nuanced not only might
people not have the right skills or
expectations for the jobs available but
our analysis has also shown they might
not necessarily be in the right places
with different regions facing different
challenges
this chart compares the number of
unemployed and furloughed people with
the rise in job vacancies in each region
the higher the dots the more people
likely looking for work the further to
the right the more vacancies it shows
that london is the worst place to be
right now if you're a worker it has the
highest number of people competing for
fewer jobs while the northern regions
face different challenges there are much
higher vacancies here and in yorkshire
in particular comparatively fewer people
to fill them
and that amounts to a rough ride for
employers at gulliver's valley rotherham
they just can't get the staff they're
fighting for young workers to stay
has been seen as the job you get before
you get your proper job well actually
the service industry is huge in this
country and we have to start making it a
prime industry and training people for
it if ever there are a symbol of the
changes to a town it's here the former
temple borough steel works now a science
center it will host sky news's first big
ideas live event experts leaders and
locals discussing these challenges and
others to come more change no doubt for
a place that's already seen plenty helen
and smith sky news rotherham
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if there's ever been a time for big
ideas this is it a country and economy
coming out of a pandemic a fuel supply
crisis leading to cues at the pumps
an economy with an unprecedented number
of job vacancies but a shortage of
skilled workers to fill them we're a
nation long on talent and ambition but
are too many regions short on
opportunity and leadership
as the world prepares for the cop 26
climate change conference how can
businesses build back green and how can
new companies challenge them
what secure work will be created once
the pandemic has been and gone in what
industries and where
it's a time for big ideas a time for
sharing them what's my big idea well
it's about big numbers and small numbers
and what that data tells us about the
world we live in now my big idea well we
need trillions to invest in the green
infrastructure we need to hit those net
zero targets that's pretty much the size
of the global savings glove so let's
talk about how we get that dead cash
deployed into the life of our planet
what could be the growth story of the
21st century
and my big idea is this i'd be
abolishing employers national insurance
contributions not putting them up if the
government wants more people in work it
ought to make hiring them easier to do
nobody's going to argue against leveling
up
but first let's decide what it actually
means it's time for big ideas live
what could be the growth story of the
21st century
the chaos economy uh and finally i know
this looks totally random but why we
need better maps
and hopefully all of these slightly odd
uh different strands of ideas will will
intertwine uh in the next 10 minutes or
so and you'll see what on earth i'm
going on about um first of all the
problem with data so you know i i am not
just economics but data editor
and so i spend a lot of time looking at
numbers i love numbers i love charts
but you know we've also got to be aware
that you know when people look at
numbers when they present data
often there's a sense that you've got
this kind of monolithic truth there
you've got a number therefore it must be
true and you know often data often
charts can tell you something pretty
insightful i mean just this morning
we had labor market data coming out
which showed us well a few things you
had the payrolled employees that's more
or less back to where it was before the
pandemic
began but look hours worked across the
economy so it's just looking at total
across the economy and all i've done is
i've rebased them to the start of the
pandemic here so you get the sense of
just how things have changed versus that
to where they are now hours work not
quite back to where they were before but
just look at this vacancies
i mean that is just the extraordinary
chart isn't it showing you
part of what perhaps you're seeing in
the labor market at the moment the fact
that vacancies are the highest level
they've ever been this is just looking
relative to the last uh to the start of
the pandemic start of january last year
but nonetheless that level is also the
highest it's ever been and that's part
of
the various different crises that we're
facing at the moment across the economy
it's not just one crisis i mean people
talk you know and you know to some
extent i think the the media is guilty
of this as well as simplifying it down
to one thing a supply shortage or a
supply crisis but actually it strikes me
you've got kind of at least four crises
maybe more than that four crises in one
you've got an energy crisis so you know
we all know about that at the moment
prices up to extraordinary levels a
distribution crisis so getting stuff
around is very difficult right now uh
you've got a labor crisis at the moment
so in terms of actually getting people
to do the work that you need to do and
then you've got a global supply crisis
and all of these things are kind of
intertwined and they they feed off into
each other but to some extent they are
four separate stories and when you look
at certain different charts of what's
going on with global prices i mean you
heard in that panel
a lot of concern about inflation right
now let me show you a chart that kind of
backs that up and i've got another one
coming up in a bit uh that will do so as
well this is just showing you prices of
certain key materials over the course of
the last couple of years so going going
back to april last year started the
pandemic over that period metals prices
across the world up by 77
crude oil up by 200 percent
and i updated this about a week ago so
it may have gone up since then food
prices up by 40 and in any kind of
normal period you know 40 increase in
food prices over about 18 months would
be considered quite a lot but just look
at what's happened to shipping costs
over that period
up by 400 and you know these are
obviously global numbers that's from the
shanghai shipping index up by 400 over
that period
put all of that together and that all
looks really quite inflationary doesn't
it and that's you know part of the the
story that we're undergoing right now
but it underlines you know we talked
about distribution crisis well there you
can see shipping up there and then
you've got an energy crisis with crude
and then you've got this kind of global
supply crisis with other materials going
up in price as well all of that starting
to feed through into the prices that
we're paying but it takes a while to go
through that kind of chain reaction now
i said that you know there are problems
with data it doesn't tell you
definitively what's going on sometimes
for certain stories for certain charts
it is really instructive but for other
charts
for other kind of
episodes it's not necessarily telling
you quite as definitive of a story as
you'd like to the data is not always
definitive and framing matters so let me
give you an example of what i mean by
framing
remember the government has talked quite
a lot recently about statistics like
this the uk is the strongest growing
economy
in the world
uh actually well they say in the g7 and
they they pull out statistics like this
and indeed that is true if you look just
at the growth in q2
there is the uk stronger than any other
economy in the g7 but here's the thing
you know the framing of that question
really matters are you just looking at
growth in the latest quarter or are you
going to look at growth com you know
where we are now compared with the start
of the pandemic because if you do that
let's just look at that different
framing same statistics same specific
gdp different framings what happens to
that red bar
it goes down there it turns out actually
the uk is not the best in the g7
actually it's somewhere kind of mid
maybe lower table
and the us these bars are just showing
you how gdp now compares or the latest
estimate compares with the start of the
pandemic and the uk kind of down there
with germany uh and france so don't be
similar to the rest of them now
framing matters also when it comes to
some of the issues that we're trying to
wrestle with at the moment and we might
talk about this this a little bit more
certainly it came up in ian's panel this
question of whether the uk is a low-wage
low-skill economy and whether that's
either problematic whether that's an
opportunity whether it's something that
we need to kind of do something about
the government talks about that a lot
about the idea of pulling us up with
higher wages to be a higher wage economy
but let's just interrogate it and ask
whether the data actually bears out that
we are
a low-wage economy these lines here all
of these bars are just showing you
different members of the oecd so
developed economies around the world and
you see the average over there and the
higher the bars are
the higher you're talking about average
net income after taxes in other words on
the basis of this
it looks like the uk is quite a
high-wage economy not a low-wage economy
because we're quite high up there
but here's the thing okay same question
again looking at whether we're a
low-wage or high-wage economy now look
at the proportion of people who are
low-paid
and this is just the higher these bars
are the more low paid people there are
of as a proportion and the uk is high up
there
so it really depends on what question
you're asking you can ask one question
you know and you know use that previous
chart to suggest that we're actually
high wage or we could use this chart to
suggest we're quite low wage and same
thing with skills as well
this might be something that you've
encountered when it comes to you know
the skilled levels this shows you low
skilled say the proportion of the
population who have low skill levels so
below secondary education um and so the
higher the bars are perversely here the
higher the bars are the more low skilled
people there are and the uk actually has
quite a small proportion of low skilled
people so we actually have decent levels
of skills when you look across the
population
but here's the thing okay the question
is whether those skills were appropriate
for the job that someone wants to do
aren't they you know it's not
necessarily particularly useful having a
degree in one thing or indeed a
qualification in one thing when you
actually want to do another job and that
comes down to a statistic called skills
mismatch the extent to which those
skills that you have or your applicant
has are appropriate for the job that you
want them to fill
the uk has the biggest skills mismatch
or one of the biggest skills mismatch in
the developed world in other words we
have lots of very skilled people but
they're not necessarily skilled in the
particular thing that they need to be to
get the job that people want them to do
so there you know you see it's a much
more nuanced issue than i think a lot of
people imply and digging into the data
sometimes helps you to understand that
but the other problem with data is that
it's not always especially definitive
and
i'm going to show you a chart here
actually
and i wonder if you can kind of guess
what
what data we're looking at here i'll
give you a clue so it starts in 1990 it
goes to 2020.
as you can see lots of lines here
a bit of a dip there
but i don't know can anyone guess
what
what this is what on earth this
statistic is
it's a pretty it's a pretty familiar one
for all of us
because this is actually
gdp
this is looking at every sector of the
economy
and their gross domestic product gross
value added
and just to underline that we really are
talking about every sector here we've
just rebased it back to 1990. let me
show you some of these sectors so it
communications up an extraordinary
amount soap and detergents i don't
realize soap and detergents have done so
well over the past
uh few decades soft drinks up a lot uh
gambling there
but the point i'm trying to make is when
you know when people talk about gdp they
don't tend to talk about this
as a big picture a very complex picture
across you know 90 100 different sectors
of the economy they just focus on one
line they focus on that line and when
we're doing a report on gdp of course we
just talk about
this line here you can see covered over
there
and we focus on that line and we tend to
ignore what's going on beneath the
surface because we've only got so much
time
but the point i want to make is that
looking beneath the surface i think is
more important now by the way we i'll
just adjust the axis there's there it is
same thing gdp but we've taken out all
of the other lines
looking beneath the surface is more
important than it's ever been before
and i think we're starting to learn that
with these kind of
various different crises we're going
through right now um and that context is
all important
let me show you what i mean about that
so i'm going to take show you gdp going
all the way back to 1300. so this is
kind of medieval gdp here and what you
can see
is that for most of history for century
after century after century after
century it was basically flat it wasn't
doing much at all
people were not necessarily getting any
richer because that's you know what what
gdp is ultimately it's just the amount
of income that we're earning across the
economy and then we divide it up by the
number of people there but it just
basically wasn't doing anything and then
look what happened after kind of around
1850
it went up and up and up and up
and that really is the story of kind of
capitalism and the story of welfare and
the story of where we are today we have
got extraordinarily richer over the
course of the last 150 200 years
and typically when people talk about why
that is
they'll talk about the industrial
revolution so you might talk about
the invention of the spinning jenny and
you know mass production of cloth uh
around manchester and other places you
might talk about the bessemer process so
very relevant for where we are now about
still making uh or take it back to
abraham derby
but the reality is okay when we look at
this line and we just have our kind of
pet theories about why it went up like
that
often you know we have a tendency to
simplify and as i say i work in the
media where we need to try and explain
something quickly and that involves
simplification but the reality is okay
let's zoom in
on that line
and think about the other things that
were going on at the same time it wasn't
just steel making it wasn't just the
making of cotton it was also the
chemicals revolution so it wasn't just
industrial revolution it was chemicals
revolution where you had processes like
the leblanc process survey process
turning salt uh into chemicals saving
millions of people's lives by making the
world cleaner we didn't talk about this
all that much do we but it's incredibly
important
uh today you've got the invention of
cement again not discussed all that much
but this is the bedrock for the built
world that we live in at the moment and
this was all happening at the same kind
of period as was the invention of
aluminium you know again incredibly
important but it was actually relatively
late that we discovered how uh to make
aluminium very energy intensive as well
uh nitrogen fixation you know feeding
the world through the harbour bosch
process i mean we've talked quite a lot
about about fertilizers recently on the
news more than we usually do frankly um
but this is a key part again
of civilization as we know it today and
here's the thing
i'm gonna go just into the modern era
there 1947 transistors you also had
solar panels around the same kind of
time and lithium-ion batteries uh in
1985. here's the thing we're not talking
about a single industrial revolution
we're talking about various different
revolutions across all parts of the
economy
and here's another thing worth bearing
in mind every single one of those
different revolutions
involves the creation in terms of the
processes whether it's cement whether
it's the chemicals revolution whether
it's lithium-ion batteries whether it's
solar panels uh whether it's aluminium
these are all very energy intensive like
incredibly energy-intensive processes
that have also involved the creation of
quite a lot of carbon
and one of the things i think hasn't
really been fully appreciated when we
talk about you know climate change
is that we need to reconsider how to
re-imagine a lot of these different
revolutions that we had that we've
achieved over over the course of the
past 200 years and it's such a big deal
it's such a big deal
and we need to talk about it a little
bit more
so let me get to that final point that i
made about why we need better maps and
what on earth i was talking about there
so i want to try and clarify that
we do a lot of talking both in sky news
in the world of economics about these
things lines lines that show you whether
gdp is going up you saw one a moment ago
lines that show you whether inflation is
going up lines that show you whether
people are getting richer
but i think this is by the way is by a
guy called john playfair it's one of the
earliest examples of charts and i love
it so it's they're so beautiful um
but we need to do
a bit less of that
and a bit more of this
we don't talk about maps enough when it
comes to economics
and what do i mean by maps we need
better maps what do i mean by maps here
well think about
what we might be facing here so it's not
the kind of map you were expecting was
it
um
the threat of a potential bacon shortage
uh in the uk
um
what is the map behind that well there
is a kind of chain reaction isn't there
that's led to this
potential bacon shortage partly there's
the kind of labor thing we talked about
a moment ago when it comes to kind of
getting enough people to work work
within agriculture but partly it's also
this a co2 shortage so not enough co2
and why do we have not enough co2 it's
because fertilizer plants shut down and
why do fertilizers plants shut down it's
because of record energy prices and why
do we have record energy prices well
it's because of a whole range of factors
you know not as much gas coming from
russia uh you have problems with uh with
the amount of gas that we're storing
here but also on top of that on the
other side of the world in china you've
got coal mines being shut down and some
of them being flooded recently
so when i talk about maps what i mean is
this kind of unexpected cascade this
chain reaction a chaos effect
where a butterfly wings flaps on one
side of the world and then suddenly
you're out of bacon on the other side of
the world
coal mine's shut down chain reaction all
the way through
we don't understand that stuff very well
and i you know certainly within the
world of economics but the reason that i
think it's you know quite significant
that we're here talking to you
is that we want to try and understand it
better
and i think it's businesses around the
country
that work within these supply chains
that understand this stuff more
intimately certainly more intimately
than the government for whom this came
as an enormous surprise and more
intimately than most of us let me give
you one other example of another kind of
chain reaction
same thing again chinese coal mine
shutdowns
why is that going to have an impact on
semiconductors
because no one really when people talk
about semiconductor shortage they're not
talking about coal mining but they
should
let me show you why
if you want semiconductors if you want
to make computer chips
you need silicone metal if you want
silicone metal you need coking coal
a lot of coking coal goes into the
production of silicone metal i need
silicone metal
to make polysilicon polysilicon to make
silicon wafers and silicone wafers to
make semiconductors
this supply chain
is not very widely understood
and yet it's incredibly important for
the way the world fits together and we
need better maps of this kind of thing
and this is what i'm talking about i'm
going to show you one more chart and
then we're going to talk to um torsten
bell who's uh who's been watching this
probably with with dismay about the idea
of having to discuss all this random
stuff but
chinese culture mine shutdowns silicon
metal this is all coming our way in
terms of semiconductor shortage right
now the shortage that we have is largely
happening within places like taiwan it's
in fabs that basically aren't able to
produce enough to kind of keep the
automobile sector uh supplied
but this side of things we don't talk
about enough but let me show you what's
happening to silicon metal prices so
that metal that you need coal for it's
been more or less flat for most of
recent history this goes all the way
back to 2016. but just recently
except earlier on september there was a
production cut of silicon metal in
yunnan province in china where a lot of
this stuff is produced just look at what
happened to the silicon metal price
and that's something that's very rarely
remarked on it's something where people
aren't really putting those pieces
together
and trying to
understand how that is about to come
down the road to us
but when we talk about inflation when we
talk about the state of the economy this
is the kind of thing uh that we should
be discussing so with that in mind i
mean we have a whole range of different
things we've discussed that we've
discussed the state of the uk labour
market we've discussed uh the extent to
which we have shortages we've discussed
what happens within supply chains and
whether we have a good understanding of
them
um i want to bring in torsten bell from
the resolution foundation uh who should
be down the line uh from uh westminster
who i hope has been listening to some of
that uh and i uh probably with with with
some uh trepidation uh i wanna start
ashley thorsten by asking you about
that question of the labor market the
question of you know whether we do have
a kind of low-wage low-skill economy
and kind of where we are on that
particular uh path
well i mean i think there's some there's
obviously some good news in that space
ed which is you know what we learned
over the last
what have we last over the last 20 years
is that yes we have been a country
with more
low paid hourly low paid people than
most similar countries
but actually having now decided to
introduce a minimum wage at the end of
the last century and then to
aggressively ramp it up under this
government over the last five years
we've actually seen a very big fall the
first fall in low pay for
four decades and it's happened without
big losses in employment so we've
learned that the country had a problem
and that policy was able to make a very
big difference to that and that you know
these are not small fry amounts of money
for people you know even just looking at
the rise since 2016 a full-time minimum
wage worker will be well over a thousand
pounds a year better off because of that
policy change
so think so things are starting to to
improve but how about where we are now
so you've got obviously universal credit
card that is going ahead or at least the
kind of temporary up left be
going uh energy price is incredibly high
right now to what extent are you seeing
the potential for real kind of pain
across the labor market and that lower
pay side of it
over the course of the next few months
well i think the whole country is set
for a difficult autumn on the costa
living side you know everyone will know
seeing their prices going up faster than
they are
used to and obviously energy prices
partly reflecting some of what you were
saying earlier ed are obviously the the
poster boys for the the cost of living
crunch that is coming big rise just
happened last week on energy prices and
another one coming in april
then so you've got prices going up i
think the thing that is particularly bad
for low-income households is that for
them
the price going up will be accompanied
by their income going down
because of the cut to universal credit
that happened last wednesday and that
will be biting for families right across
the next the next month as their lower
benefit payments come through and we're
not talking about a small change we're
talking about a thousand pounds a year
for
well over four million households on
average people losing five percent of
their income
overnight so yeah i think it is a really
tough autumn coming it's a tough autumn
for everybody because everyone has to
pay their energy bills but it's
particularly tough for lower middle
incomes households who
those
areas of spending food and energy are
particularly large amounts of their
spending and as i say for lots of them
their income is coming down too
and so since you had to sit through like
like our excellent audience here had to
sit through my slightly random
set of charts about supply chains about
energy about all of these different
factors i just wanted to get your take
uh
on that i mean you know we're living in
a world now where
these things seem to be cropping up
quite a lot
and i wonder you know does does brexit
play a part in that that's been one of
those things that's been discussed do we
do we do we have the right kind are we
looking at the right things to
understand what's coming down the line
you know i thought your um economic and
science history lesson was actually
really valuable because
one of the things
i think that we need to just understand
is modern economies are very complex
okay and in general we have spent the
last kind of 40 50 years moving away
from the idea of planning our economy
moving away from the idea that the
government does understand those supply
chains that you were drawing out and
moving towards a liberal view which is
the job of government is to provide
stability and then we should leave
individuals and firms to make those
supply chains work well because trying
to plan them is beyond uh is beyond what
is possible from sitting with a
spreadsheet in westminster and in
general obviously that's true because as
you illustrated
there's lots of complex interactions in
supply chains that economists aren't
going to understand and you don't have
to be very liberal to think uh that it's
beyond the width of a central planner to
get it right when it's guessing what the
future looks like so in general that's
true
where that becomes difficult
is when big shocks happen
when big change happens and you saw that
in the financial crisis when everybody
who previously loved financial
innovation and complex financial
products suddenly decided that those
products were a real risk to the
financial stability of the country and
that we didn't well understand them and
the version of that this time
is that not understanding our industrial
supply chains in particular
is proving very difficult when we've
been through two years of turning our
economy off and turning it back on again
and that is then causing us a whole
world of problems which you illustrated
very
uh very neatly obviously the uk is
unusual
in the economic change we're going
through
is the ones that other big developed
countries are going through which is net
zero plus covid
and we are adding to that the big change
that brexit
brings and i think stepping back and
thinking about the 2020s i think it is
really important to think about it in
the way you set out because this is not
just oh can we please get back to some
kind of vague normal after these crisis
it's about recognizing that the 2020s is
an era of unusual economic change as
brexit covid net zero all happen at once
and that does bring new economic
challenges understanding changes to
these supply chains understanding how
some kinds of workers are going to be
asked to make bigger changes in their
lives than we're used to because i know
everyone says oh you know change has
been speeding up for decades that
actually isn't true
it's actually we've been seeing less
change in most aspects of our economy
over recent decades and i think that's
why the next decade is a particularly
big challenge for us because a lot of
change is coming
thank you okay that's that's fascinating
to us and glad glad to hear that i
wasn't talking total rot there the
audience here will be very reassured to
get your expert take uh on that and uh
thank you very much for appearing at big
ideas live thank you torsten bell from
the resolution foundation there uh from
london now i i just want to finish off
by by saying that you know as torsten
was was saying understanding this stuff
is going to be really important for for
all of us
we
are you know at the forefront of trying
to explain this stuff but the reason
that we're trying to come and talk to as
many people as possible is that we think
this is not necessarily a well-developed
and well understood
part of the way the economy actually
fits together and genuinely the
government doesn't either i know people
within number 10 within the treasury who
are only beginning now to try to piece
together those maps i was talking about
right then it's not about having maps
like that so you can intervene it's
about having maps so you can understand
i mean you know good intervene if you
wanted to but it's about having maps so
you can understand what is going on
what's coming down the line what is the
impact going to be of decarbonisation
what's the impact going to be of brexit
our intelligence of this is really quite
primitive at the moment and so the more
we can try to understand that the better
we're going to understand the economy
which is why you know random as it is i
think that we need more maps
now later on uh my colleague dr mark
carney mark really good to see you this
morning i appreciate you getting up
super early at canadian time to speak to
us i wanted to start by talking to you
mark if i may about cop 26 just over two
weeks to go i know you've been working
very hard towards it
prince charles says there's a chance it
could just be all talk how confident are
you that we'll see some action at that
conference
uh well first it's great to see you sam
and thanks for having me uh
we are seeing action uh we need to see
more but we are seeing big action and as
you know i'm concentrating on the
private financial sector so city of
london but really the global financial
sector
and there's two big things we need to do
for coff the first is to change the i'll
use a metaphor the plumbing of the
system so the information the tools
create some new markets there's 24 very
wonky detailed things that needed to be
done for cobb they're all going to be
completed for glasgow so that's the
first thing and that what that does is
it reorients the system to
providing capital to move towards net
zero or where our economy needs to go
where the world needs to go the second
big thing we need to do is to get a very
large amount of money
that is going to be lent and invested
towards that net zero to help drive our
economy forward but also help get
emissions down and as we meet today
the number of banks insurers
big pension funds around the world
who've committed to that
that number 18 months ago was 5 trillion
5 trillion today it's over 90 trillion
nine zero trillion dollars and so
there's been an enormous shift in that
uh in the run-up to [ __ ] we're
continuing to build that uh momentum
into cops so that we have enough money
that's needed for the investment to make
the transition so i think we're seeing
more a lot more than talk
but but you in order for it to be a
success you need the big countries there
the big finances there particularly the
big emitters is china coming can it be a
success without them yeah um so we need
we need many things there's no one
solution as you well know and uh you're
absolutely right we need the countries
to step up
and just in the shorthand what we're
trying to achieve for cop is that the
ambition of countries the policies of
countries and then of course the actions
of companies
and uh banks and others is consistent
with one and a half degrees limiting
temperature increases to one and a half
degrees
right now we're not on that trajectory
the commitments of countries are
estimated to add up to 2.1 degrees
that's better than it was a few years
ago but it's not good enough
so we need to see additional progress
china itself has moved very importantly
in the last 12 months it committed to
net zero that was a first for a major
emerging economy and it's made some
additional commitments around coal in
recent months uh we need to see more
from them we need to see more candidly
from virtually everybody yeah but if
canada and australia and other big
emitter don't come it doesn't give you
that urgency that you need does it well
um what we have is that in recent months
um canada for example went from a 30
uh objective to a 45 objective by 2030
so a different path for emissions uh we
saw an increase the u.s stepped up for
the first time going to 50 down by 2030
their objective so all of those big
so-called g7 countries have been moving
the you know the prime minister and
others have been working very hard on
this aspect of it so we're getting
movement in some of the big advanced
economies look sam they have to deliver
and one of the ways they can deliver is
to have that finance that money that i
was talking about earlier being lined up
and then put to work
there is more momentum than perhaps
meets the eye and let me give you one
other figure which is important 18
months ago uk started the presidency
less than one third of global emissions
were covered by these net zero
commitments such as the uk has now it's
more than three quarters so there's been
a huge shift in 18 months again we need
to mainta you know continue with that
momentum and get more into glasgow which
is why we're meeting and mark i know
you're advising the prime minister um
the uk clearly needs to set an example
here we're hosting the conference
um its own independent committee has
been critical of the uk government's
lack of plan
are you aware of a detailed uk
government plan to get us to net zero
well first thing to say and i have
the opportunity to see approaches around
the world given my role and the uk's
overall approach is absolutely the right
one in the following respects one it has
a very clear objective secondly it has
as you say an independent committee
which assesses how good our policies are
relative to that objective and what that
committee the climate change committee
is saying is that there's a gap between
what we're saying is our objective and
where the policies are
and it's identifying the size of that
gap now that's okay in the sense of
there are always other budgets there's
always additional plans and there's
additional things being put in place and
the uk has been stepping up whether it's
on when whether it's on the moratorium
on internal combustion engines
whether it's on the hydrogen the
hydrogen economy yes more needs to be
done but we have a much better idea in
the uk
where the gap is between ambition and
action yeah
and governments can put forward i would
stress it again as well that the uk
financial system and that's not just our
banks but very much our insurers and
pension funds have moved hugely and in
many respects are leading this and this
can help pull forward uh the adjustment
that the governments need to make but
government climate policy needs to be
credible doesn't it mark is it helpful
that there is an inquiry as to whether
we should be
building a new coal mining cumbria and
doing oil and gas exploration up in
scotland
yeah well i think uh let me let me put
it this way i think it is helpful that
an inquiry is being done into this and
independent inquiry is being done to
this because it shows exactly what the
issues are around the transition uh
let's take the example of the uh of the
coal uh mine in cumbria which is cold
being used for steel not coal being used
for power generation but still has an
environmental impact if it's done uh
there is a gap between um the life of
that coal mine it could run until 2050
effectively
the life of that coal mine and what
our trajectory needs to be in the uk in
order to get to net zero a coal mine
like that really can only run in the
judgment of that independent panel until
2035. so what it does this approach is
it shines a light on how we need to
change and it forces us to think much
more carefully about putting in place
new investments in carbon intensive
sectors um and much greater intention uh
focus on transitioning from you know the
old economy to the new economy in a way
that's growing our growing jobs and uh
and income in terms of credibility mark
wouldn't it have just been easier just
to say no we're not going there
uh well i think look i i'm not a member
of the government they have to follow a
process there's a judicial review
quasi-judicial review i guess is the way
i would put it the decision was called
in by the by the government the national
government from the from the local level
it's being reviewed my understanding is
that that decision will happen by the
end of this year so you
we have to respect process in these
things um and uh i i would suggest that
the pro the process and the fact we're
talking about it and it gets out the you
know the realities of what a transition
is and where we need to go uh is
actually
you know hey it's the right thing to do
you have to follow due process as i say
but it also brings to life uh the real
issues underlying this yeah final
question on this before we get on onto
the financing which is i i know what
you'd like to talk about a style point
some of the language used by the prime
minister around green issues bunny
huggers quoting kermit the frog does
that kind of language help with
illustrating the urgency of what you're
trying to achieve on the environment
uh it's certainly it's certainly
memorable
and
the prime minister does
range widely in terms of his metaphors
and uh but he's uh but there's not
language you'd be using you're not going
to be quoting kermit the frog yourself
no okay all right i sense uh you've said
all you want to say on that let's talk
about the climate finance then um
falling short of what was pledged in
copenhagen 100 billion dollars a year
for developing nations is it the united
states that's holding things up because
they seem to have the biggest
bridge to build
here yeah so the first thing to say is
for anyone coming to this new or not
following a day to day the numbers are
absolutely enormous so um what you're
asking about is as you know 100 billion
dollars a year this was a pledge of
the rich countries basically to help the
poorer countries developing economies
with the transition it was made 10 years
ago in copenhagen and we haven't met it
yet and it's one of the key objectives
for the uk for this for glasgow for cop
is to get to that number now two weeks
ago there was the meeting of the un
general assembly prime minister was
there
and actually the u.s stepped up they
doubled their commitment to over 11
billion i think it's 11.4 billion uh
dollars
there are a number of other countries
who are looking to potentially add to
theirs canada and germany are managing
and process not me personally but others
uh managing a process to get to that
hundred billion number it's very
important but at the same time and i
apologize to your audience um just to
put in context we need to multiply that
by a thousand
uh in terms of additional uh
capital additional finance in other
words we need not just a hundred billion
dollars we need a hundred trillion
dollars over the next uh two decades two
and a half decades in order to get to
where we need to go and the point that
we've recognized very early on is that's
only going to come from the private
sector which is why there's been such a
focus on the things i was talking about
at the start which is to get the private
sector aligned uh to move money towards
uh companies and projects that are
solutions to this problem yeah um
while we've got you mark we're running
out of time i do want to ask you about
the uk economy quite a few spasms in it
at the moment we've got all the coved
scarring of course cost of living crisis
uh energy crisis as well what's your
take
well uh the uk is going through as as
others are but maybe a little more
sharply the uk is going through a series
of uh
supply shocks to use the economic term
we have the adjustment from covet and
acceleration of changes in business
whether it's on the digital side perhaps
most prominently
we have the big move in energy prices
which which we're seeing elsewhere but
more so in the uk which
brings its own impact uh we have the
aftermath of uh brexit and the
readjustment of the economy that comes
so we have all three of those factors
coming together um and it's uh it it
means by and and we have the beginnings
of this net zero transition we're really
at the early stages of it uh and it
means that um uh there are some
frictions in the economies and and and
adjustments that are necessary
can i ask you as well i can't resist
really i mean the supply chain ruptures
labor shortages disputes over the good
friday agreement
do you feel like one of those derided
experts who was opining on these things
in the run-up to the referendum back in
2016 who now feels a bit like i told you
so
absolutely i mean
our job the bank of england's job and
the run-up uh to both the referendum but
very much to brexit itself was to make
sure the financial system was in a
position to be part of the solution i
think what we have seen
is that the financial system uk
financial system has stood up as a
through this period including of
disruption and what at least i'm doing
and working with others including the
bank of england the treasury
more broadly is making sure the
financial system is ready and part of
the solution for climate change so
moving on to the next big thing
and and that's what we can do of course
part of making sure that it was ready
was to look at what could go wrong and
the types of supply chains and
inflationary and other impacts that
could come
from the uh the adjustment the initial
phase of adjustment and uh i think what
people can
look it may be cold comfort to some
extent but uh you know be reassured that
the uk financial system is very strong
uh and uh it's part of the solution both
in the short term
and what we're doing for glasgow is
making sure that it is part of the
solution
for this transition towards net zero and
the last point if i may and that is the
transition that will i saw its uh graphs
earlier that will continue to grow this
economy uh
at a speed that people expect i noticed
you sidestepped there without the whole
i told you so point but but we'll we'll
move on um calls from the energy
industry for state support and also
energy intensive businesses um wanting
state support i know i don't want to
drag you into uk government policy but
given the urgency of the environmental
problem is it even appropriate for that
conversation to be being had
well i think what um
short-term moves uh underscore is that
we need a comprehensive plan for the
transition um there are
and we need to try to have a transition
that is smoother rather than choppy
uh and
so part of that is that policy that you
were talking about earlier we needed to
be predictable and credible um in terms
of energy policy uh in addition um
sometimes it is appropriate for some
support particularly for the users of
energy uh in in those sectors uh but i i
yes as you suggested in your preamble
i'd leave it to the government who's
much closer to these issues to make
those determinations
uh and final question uh thought from
you mark um in paris the notable
achievement was to get countries to dare
to imagine that maximum temperature
increase of of one and a half degrees
what do you think could be the headline
from glasgow
i think uh absolutely we've got to keep
one and a half degrees alive so
imagination is one thing and vision is
one thing but action is what's needed
so we have a few more weeks
we will do everything we can on the
financial sector to ensure that there's
real action and commitment so that the
money is there what's clear is that the
money is there for the transition that's
one core plank we need for glasgow the
second is that countries step up uh not
just with ambition but with policy that
uh meets that ambition i said final
question i do have one more for you i
mean you talk about the green recovery
inclusive growth the multiplier effect
kicking in um
that's going to mean an end to historic
low interest rate rises isn't it so the
whole world's going to have to adjust to
that
well um
a couple of things one is that we have
been in a very difficult place for the
last decade
since the financial crisis with
exceptionally low in
interest rates in order to keep our
economy going effectively it's been the
right policy
but it's not a desirable place to be and
the only way to move out of that is to
have bigger structural changes and very
positive ones which mean a lot of
investment we need an additional two
percentage points of gdp that's an
enormous amount of investment um in
order to make this transition it is
feasible we've got the money now in
order to make it um but that will help
to
grow first the economy secondly and
relatedly incomes and jobs of people and
in that
positive environment then it would be
appropriate to have higher interest
rates um to keep the economy going all
else equal but that's a good this is
this is good news
and by the way it's good news for savers
it's good news for a lot of people
but it is not being punished by higher
interest rates it's a consequence of
positive outcomes so yes i i hope we get
there
we've got some more work to do
until we do though
all right it's been fascinating talking
to you this morning mark again thank you
for getting up early to speak to us we
look forward to seeing you in glasgow at
cop26 and wishing you all the best of
luck with it thank you very much indeed
dr mark carney there for you back over
to you adam in australia well with our
sky news team um there's been a lot to
take on board hasn't there today we've
been hearing a lot about the economy the
various pressures on it at the moment
the jobs market
how to get higher wage work back into
the economy as well we also heard the
former bank of england governor's view
of the current state of the economy and
talking about some particular cost
pressures that are particular
to the uk um importantly as well we got
on to the green agenda and what he's
hoping to get out of cop26 of course
time for that very much
running out to get those pledges through
the door we need to be talking about
that as with our panel as part of our
next big idea um as the world comes out
of the pandemic we need to be thinking
about how businesses build back green
and also how they build back their
balance sheets as well and the
inevitable tensions between those two uh
we'll be talking about what the
government can be doing what it is doing
what it should be doing uh all of that
i'll be discussing all of that with my
panel who kindly assembled here for us
this afternoon but first our business
correspondent helen ann smith i'd like
to welcome her back onto the stage
because she is going to set the scene
ahead of our discussion helena thank you
sam afternoon everyone so it is now
pretty well established and pretty well
agreed upon that cutting emissions is in
theory the right thing to do what's a
lot less clear is not just how we do it
but crucially who should be doing what
and importantly as well how exactly are
we going to pay for it so first of all
let's just take a look at where we're at
post this big economic recession we've
had this huge shock to the economy
has it left us with emissions that are
higher or lower than what they were
before the pandemic well the answer is
um so so as you can see there the pink
line is the uk average so the average
emissions were ever so slightly below
what they were that 100 line uh in 2019
and we've plotted on a couple of key
sectors there and as you can see the
general story is that yes there were a
bit of fluctuations particularly there
in the spring when we came out of
lockdown the economy all reopening but
things were sort of roughly what they
were the key outlier an exception as you
can see in the orange there aviation
emissions in that sector significantly
down but of course we all know that
wasn't necessarily by design but because
of the restrictions that that sector was
laboring under now a lot of people said
that as we were pumping billions into
the economies different countries doing
that to recover from the pandemic this
would have been a really good excuse a
really good opportunity to invest in
more green and did countries do that did
they use this opportunity
to make their recovery spending green
spending so essentially what we've done
along the bottom line here is the
percentage of covered recovery spending
in different countries that was green
spending up on this axis here
essentially at the proportion of a
country's gdp that the spending was and
as you can see there are a couple of
countries belgium canada who really did
prioritize uh green spending as part of
their recoveries but the larger
economies particularly those as well who
were very hard hit by the pandemic
not so much and essentially i think what
this is showing us is that when chips
were down when times were hard it is
difficult to prioritize this type of
spending and perhaps that's not hugely
surprising because we know this stuff is
expensive we know it is really really
difficult and i want to just show you
this just to give a bit of an insight
about just how difficult and just how
expensive it might be this is the uk's
uh sort of domestic carbon emissions uh
going back to 1990. as you can see
they're going down we know that the
targets are to hit net zero by 2050 but
just look at this when we add in the
emissions that comes just from the
import
of goods so that part of domestic trade
hugely higher uh probably hugely harder
to bring down and we have to ask
ourselves after a summer of supply chain
problems the importance that we're
placing on global global trade right now
are we going to have the stomach to
really radically overhaul that system
and how we're going to do it it's going
to be very very difficult uh indeed so
who is doing what well what this is
showing you is the percentage of
companies cities states and regions and
countries who have actually made net
zero promises so far so 61 percent of
countries have made some sort of net
zero promise but look companies only 21
of the 2000 largest companies in the in
the world have made a net zero pledge at
all however when you look at the quality
of the net zero pledges that have been
made by countries and companies slightly
different story this big chunk in the
yellow here from the countries
essentially shows us that of those net
zero promises that have been made a lot
of them are just at that stage of
proposal or discussion however companies
when they have made a zero promise much
more likely to be in the purple they're
in policy document and strategy
essentially a sense that if a net zero
promise is made by a company it's being
taken a little bit more seriously worth
just pointing out that orange bit there
companies have actually achieved more of
their net zero promises as well but
still at pretty low levels so huge
problems huge challenges not just in
terms of what to do but how to
prioritize it and very crucially as i
said as well who's going to pay for it
sam thank you
isn't it
thank you
as i was saying to discuss what
companies and government we can see what
they've pledged and what they're
actually doing can do to promote green
growth i'm now joined by four people
around here with direct experience of
policy and indeed in practice uh in the
area we have at
the managing director of allah foods uk
welcome to you we have diane gilpin
chief executive and co-founder of smart
green shipping alliance welcome to you
as well we also have lindy stone from
friends of the earth the sheffield
coordination
for friends of the earth there and we
have vicky price an economist and former
joint head of the uk's government
economic service so thank you very much
for giving up your time to join this
discussion here with us all in rotherham
um i want to start by
asking you what your perception of the
uk economy is i mean it feels a bit like
it's at a fulcrum moment as hopefully we
emerge from
from the pandemic we have green issues
very pressing
um and a num number of short-term issues
as well we were hearing about mark
carney's perspective on it all earlier
um if i could start with our
business owners um
ash to you
first because some of these short-term
issues i imagine are things that are
impinging quite a lot on the way that
you normally do business if you just
give us your broader perspective on the
economy and
the state of your business as you try
and navigate through that so we're a
food business
and of course like other food businesses
have been navigating the pandemic making
sure that food flows to consumers
and
there's been a number of disruptions all
the way through i guess the disruptions
that we're working with at the moment is
a shortage of labour particularly driver
labour
that's an industry-wide problem
and just simply being able to get the
product from our factories to the
supermarkets is a real challenge um what
sort of size labour shortage are we
talking with you so we we
um are very mechanized when it comes to
our production of milk and dairy
products in the factories but we need
drivers to to take that to uh to the
shops uh and on average we're delivering
to about 2 300 shops a day
and we're regularly not able to deliver
to about 10 of our shops so that gives
you a bit of an idea of the type of
shortage that we're dealing with and
this is a very kind of
you know everyday item so when shops
don't have milk that tends to sort of
cause concern um and
and therefore the the type of issues
that we're facing as a business at the
moment tend to be more operational um
stability type issues
and i guess at the same time we're
making sure that we still have that
longer look
on how we develop our business in the uk
so whether that's capital investments to
bring more production handle the
production of our farmers but also make
the necessary investments in becoming
more climate friendly which i'm sure
we'll talk about more as the panel
develops yeah of course
many things to discuss i just want to
come back to you on on one thing in
terms of investing in the various
aspects of your business and do you have
the confidence to be doing that at the
moment because the economy economy it
feels like it could go any which way
doesn't it at the moment
yeah i mean i think it's uh it's it's
it's coming out of the pandemic and
there's still a lot of uncertainty as as
we go into the future investment is a
um we're a farmer-owned business so our
farmers actually own us and an
investment is something that we're very
used to doing over a very long period of
time and therefore um we have continued
to do that in all of our operations so
our farmers uh you know
are very keen to stay in farming you
know for generations and therefore the
investments that they make are not just
short-term capital investments but
with the idea that the next generation
will have a farm that's in a better
state than they uh they inherited
themselves and just a final word from
you before i move on to diane about um
how this huge hike in energy prices
might have impacted your business
it's impacted all aspects of our
business
and energy is clearly one of the key
cost drivers but labour
it's another one where food companies
are packaging risers as well so
inflation would be one of the key issues
that we're navigating as a business okay
and uh diane let's bring you in here and
interested very much to know your view
of the economy but also if you could
just give our audience a bit more of an
idea about your business and what you do
yeah so we're a purpose-driven startup
and we focus on the global maritime
industry
and so
in 2018 and 2019 we invented a wing sale
and went through a feasibility process
with academics
demonstrated that we could save 20 fuel
and emissions from
huge ships by retrofitting this
technology and we're on a roll and it's
going great and everybody's really
enthusiastic about it i feel like
there's a butt coming that's about
coming covered comes and so the mum so
it really takes the wind out of our
sails you know the moment literally the
momentum goes
um
everybody's focusing now on how do we
deal with this pandemic how do we deal
with this crisis and so having a startup
to come along and knock on your door and
say oh by the way would you like to have
that conversation we were having it no
we don't because we're focusing on very
survival
so
what the impact of that is so so i the
way that i see this
covid crisis is that it's a kind of
there's a word that i've heard
shudderation is that what's what it
feels like the economy has just come to
a kind of shuddering
a halt it's still moving forward
but is this an opportunity for us to
start to rethink how we build it for the
future and what do you think what's your
initial thought my thought is we have no
option i mean the climate crisis is so
great that it makes covid seem like you
know something that we we managed quite
well and i think we've got a lot of
lessons to learn from how we manage
covid um and we can we can do the same
with the climate crisis so i think
there's a lot to to learn but it isn't
easy
and it's talking about those lessons is
there anything that you think that was
the key lesson that needs to be carried
over
for the way the economy needs to now
develop yeah so i think what we've been
seeing is a gap between invention and
innovation so we we're good at inventing
stuff we're good at doing lab-based uh
research and then we're not great at
supporting pilot projects and and then
we
we then put that technology out into the
world and other countries come and scale
it up for us what we saw in the pandemic
was that all of the r d the research and
development that had been done in the
pharmaceutical industry laid the
groundwork for the vaccines to be
produced in record quick time and that
was because there was a focus this is an
emergency there's a focus let's put the
money behind it and we need that same
gap funding on pilots and demonstrators
in renewable energy and green projects
yeah it's interesting isn't it how
necessity is always the mother of
invention and innovation from what
you're saying there vicky i want to
bring you in here i know economists
never agree on anything you're famous
for it i'm interested to know
what your assessment is of the uk
economy
now and how well we are positioned to
embark on a green uh
building back green well for the moment
of course as we know we're in the middle
of a gas crisis we almost had a fuel
crisis there'll be other crisis as well
because inflation is going up all across
the world commodity prices going up
staff shortages you're covering that
earlier of course in the economic
session you had
so all these things are extra precious
for firms now if you are to seriously
move into greening your manufacturing or
your processes more generally or your
offering then you do need to spend some
money to be able to do that and right
now there is huge pressure on
working capital quite a lot of firms are
seriously indebted um of course they
were helped by the government during the
the covet crisis
that period is coming to an end and of
course there are still loans outstanding
which are on low interest terms and over
a period of year years that they have to
be repaid but nevertheless they need
more and the new loans that they're
taking are more expensive and require
all sorts of collateral and so on so
smes are suffering the big firms
particularly the energy intensive ones
are suffering too and yet we are relying
on the big firms in particular to do
that investment so what it requires now
is for the focus to switch to
an awful lot of risk sharing from
government so yes we heard from dan
about the issues of innovation
and can you really
upscale whatever it is that you develop
as a pilot
and that requires
quite a lot of risk to be taken by firms
because you don't really know which
technology is going to work in the
future the government needs to
absolutely step in to because some of
those sectors are not yet profitable are
they and solar and wind are looking good
electric vehicles looking good but
there's still a lot of sectors that
perhaps you're taking more of a risk
well some of course which are becoming
very profitable again
are banks so the financial sector is
doing reasonably well and of course
quite a lot of the firms depend on money
coming to them from the banks but of
course what the banks are also saying is
a number of sectors are not going to be
sustainable in the long term because the
the climate change issues are such that
you know even if you're in the house
building sector are you going to be
building the types of houses which are
indeed going to be
insulated sufficiently they could
survive any climate change changes that
take place uh the heat and so on or
whatever it is that may emerge which is
very different to what we've got now
so they're going to be a lot more
cautious in terms of who they lent to so
again you know you have an issue there
too as to whether a number of the firms
that
make up now the the ftse 100 or the
wider
list of companies that are in the stock
market whether many of them will be able
to even get the loans that they need in
the future so i think we are at the
point where a decision is to be made is
what type of economy we're going to have
and what we're going to be supporting
but you can't let quite a lot of the
companies which at present
hire so many people
and which are quite important in terms
of exporting and in terms of prosperity
in this economy to just go under
as
there was a fear just a few days ago
that would happen because the government
wasn't stepping in to help some sectors
of course you help them to transition
but we now realize that transition is
expensive yeah and i didn't think we put
enough money aside for that i don't know
whether you heard uh some of the numbers
that mark carney was coming out with but
he said that relatively short period a
time ago there was about five trillion
that has been put aside from balance
sheets going into meeting net zero
commitments that number is now 90
trillion so there's been a lot of
progress in a short period of time do
you read any optimism into that or do
you just think it's a drop in the ocean
no the good news is that uh because of
covert when nobody was investing the
sectors that did quite well and the
companies that equal well did put some
money aside so there has been a huge
difference between you know some sectors
that really survived quite well the
crisis and others that needed an awful
lot of help there is a lot of money
aside that hasn't been invested a lot of
money held by hedge funds so even you
know one hedge fund blackrock is is
reported to have assets of about
9 trillion anyway
and that money is not right now being
invested more generally across the world
economy in
projects which can be productive and and
lead to perhaps the types of stuff we
want to see happen in the future in
terms of technology
a lot of it is being used to buy
government bonds or is being used to buy
back shares now dividends are beginning
to be uh you know return to shareholders
again so uh that money is there the real
question is is it going to be used the
right way
what we're finding though now which is
very useful is that
governments at least are beginning to
move a lot more into raising money
through the issuing of green bonds so
the eu is doing that today it's the
first green bond 12 billion now of
course 12 billion in relation to the
trillions we've just been talking about
is nothing but at least it's a start
isn't it um we have had a question from
the audience which i'm going to pose in
a moment but lindy i want to bring you
in here because i don't want you to be
sitting there twisting in the wind while
we're all talking um vicky was saying
there that we need to decide what kind
of economy we want do you think the
conditions are right now for a green
recovery for a recovery for economic
growth where the environment is at the
heart of it
well i'm certainly here as a an amateur
and i i you know bound to the expertise
around the table um i'm a local
representative of an international
campaigning organisation which puts me
in a different sort of criteria gives me
a different look in it certainly um
amidst all the horrors of the pandemic
last year and difficulties the the
phrase emerged within the campaigning
organizations not not from government
but the phrase emerged to build back
better and this did seem as though it
was an opportunity to do things
differently um in indeed in the way that
diane and vicky have picked up already
um
and that ash referred to as well in
terms of looking at the business so
i liked that idea of the shuddering and
the shuddering of the economy because it
certainly felt as though something
different could happen and had to happen
last
last year it had to happen as a result
of the pandemic and we certainly feel
that that is a moment that needs to be
grasped it's it's an
a terrible thing to say but it's an
opportunity to do things differently
because
a mindset shift it's the mind brought
about it is and to a certain extent the
very
uh the extent and the range of things
that were done to uh counter the
pandemic the uh the innovation through
the vaccination and the you know the
development of medical treatment
actually made you realize how things can
be done if they are taken seriously so
we were actually taken very quickly
because it had to be with the pandemic
people were dying
are you do you have any confidence that
the government has a detailed plan for
its own net zero commitments have they
sort of got that urgency into their
climate thinking
um i have absolutely no confidence in
that and i think that would be shared by
most climate campaigners because
the it is always it's always true isn't
it that the urgent trumps the important
and the immediacy of the crisis that
we're facing on a day-by-day basis um
obviously most um notably but with the
you know the fuel prices the gas prices
that are currently happening distract
from the longer term issues that need to
be addressed
because we have to do stuff about the
problem today
we are each time putting off and putting
off action on the crises which are going
to hit us further down the road and
clearly the climate nature crises for
those of us who are who spend a lot of
time thinking about these issues um
need addressing need addressing urgently
and the longer you leave it the more
devastating the consequences will be
and the more problem there will be in
addressing it i was quite um
i think taken aback when i first was
aware of the yorkshire and
yorkshire and homicide climate
commission that they are both looking at
mitigation of reducing the carbon impact
of industries and organizations around
in our in our area but also that they're
spending a lot of their energy on on a
um adaptation so we know that there's
going to be massive floods we know that
hull is in danger of going underwater in
50 years time or i'm not necessarily
getting those figures completely right
and that we are going to need to spend a
lot of money
uh countering the all the effects of
climate change that have already arisen
as well as
preventing them getting worse in the
future so the the important cannot be
allowed to be trumped by the urgent and
we need the government to take more
significant action well it feels like a
good time to bring in a question from
our audience we have a question from zoe
loveday from ssk
uk where are you zoe um talking about
the role of government and i suppose
also thinking about how much
of this should be carrot versus stick
yes hello um my question is almost
prefaced by everybody has an
environmental impact or sitting here in
this room today has an environmental
impact and ssk sheffield sustainable
kitchens has had an environmental
um conscience for the past 14 years
obviously he's become a lot more trendy
nowadays of you know green washing has
become much more widespread but my
question is what would you want to see
as
the
next sustainable step changes for the
industry from either the government or
other or the wider markets to be able to
support smes to make more environment
environmentally conscious decisions more
quickly
you know sustainability is expensive we
everybody has a choice to make
sustainable decisions all the time
whether it's personal whether it's
commercial they are not necessarily and
it was touched on before economically
viable at the time and what
what can be done in terms of education
in terms of actions in terms of
accountability to flow further through
industry and down supply chains to
support smes that do want to
proceed with this in future
diane do you want to pick that up yeah
i'd love to thank you um so i think
so i think what we need to be focusing
on the ipcc report that came out in
august referred to the urgent need to
drive down emissions in the short term
you know we've got lots of plans about
decarbonizing the economy by 2050 or
2040 or something like that what can we
do tomorrow what can we do and i think
there are countless smes who are
coming up with all sorts of ideas and
solutions and we don't get a seat at the
table very often it's driven by big
business and there's a lot of money in
big business and it's critically
important i mean i think one of the
things i want to say is that we can't go
from you know where we are today to a
totally decarbonized economy overnight
it's not it's a transition we have to do
it in a transformational way but there
are there are
things that we can do now that will
start to drive down short-term emissions
and the thing that i would like to see
um
two things i think i'd like to see
subsidies removed from fossil fuels
because that provides a really
unbalanced
playing field we see um the global
economy is driven by
fossil fuels which are subsidised to the
tune i think the international monetary
fund last week said uh 11 million
dollars a minute
and so when you're saying when we're
saying that environmental products are
more expensive we're not competing
directly but if we were to get 11
million dollars a minute to support the
transition to green economy then we
wouldn't be expensive perhaps i think
that that's a really important thing to
be doing i think the other thing that's
important is that there is hardware
technology in wave wind tidal in our
sector in maritime where there are lots
of smes who are developing solutions
that can drive down emissions in the
short term uh in the next two or three
years start to take carbon and emissions
out of the environment now or buy time
for those other
big
energy transitions to alternative fuels
to kick in and start putting hardware to
test and to pilot
so that we can get verifiable results
because nobody wants to buy something
that hasn't been trialled so we've got
this technology it's great everybody in
the industry says they love it we'll buy
it when we've seen it work in action we
cannot for love nor money get well love
probably we can't get the funding to
take it to trial and it's a tiny tiny
amount of money particularly in the
context of you know 90 trillion
dollars was it yeah
um the constant thread coming through
all of this is the the tension that
exists with you know in business when
you're
trying to pay your staff and all the
rest of it um between the bottom line
and your environmental
credentials and ash i'm interested in in
your business i know that you pledged to
cut carbon emissions by 30 percent i
think by 2030 and you're also very
focused on this even back as early as
2005 when you were cutting back on
single-use plastic
i believe so you'll have a good
long case study as to how
those kind of actions have impacted
your bottom line perhaps you just talk
us through it
yeah no i think
we've had a long history of you know we
rely on the land so we don't exist
unless we we show respect
for the land and we take that uh
responsibility um seriously so our
farmer owners have been
uh collecting data so doing climate
check data actually they actually
started a a complete company-wide
program where 9 000 individual farmers
you could say individual smes
of a larger organization they collected
2000 points of data around climate
exactly what data and it was everything
from the carbon footprint of the farm
the emissions the various differences
maybe the welfare um what happens to the
water usage so a lot of data and that
data is very useful when you aggregate
it because first it gives you a relative
and absolute position in terms of our
footprint but enables us then to compare
data
and drive programs within the business
to improve our position i think the
challenge
when i talk to my farmers
is that they
realize and they have ideas and we do
trials of things that reduce our climate
impact but they typically take
investment
right and and typically the challenge
for a farmer is how do i balance that
decision between investing further and
then farming projects that i know are
ultimately right for the farm as well
over the long period of term
economically but in the short term it
costs versus all the other pressures
that i've got whether it's labor
inflation and so on and i guess what our
farmers are calling out loud and clear
as we go into the sort of period of cop
26
is a clear and an ambiguous kind of
statement from government for its
support for industries like ours or
sectors like ours that are being
proactive
on climate and initiatives and therefore
giving confidence for the investment
we're not actually asking for the money
we want the confidence that our
investment will pay off yeah we've got a
question from the audience which i'll
come to in in just a moment but i'm
interested as well in the
in the sort of philosophical tussle that
you might have i mean agriculture uh
contributes more than 10
of emissions globally
um
do we need to get to a point where
people need to just stop eating what
you're selling
well well i guess there's a there's a
big debate around the food products that
we um so so our perspective on it is
that um we take our responsibility um
and and we think everyone is responsible
uh for the for their role uh in in the
health of the planet and and we think
about it in terms of the planet and in
terms of people
so we see that it's also important to
feed people we've got a growing
population and actually the product that
we're in dairy
is safe affordable and accessible to
many parts of the world as well and
therefore we need to be able to continue
doing that but then also reduce our
impact on the climate so the way that we
look at it philosophically is that if
we're committed proactive and reducing
our impact on the climate then actually
that gives us permission then to do the
safe affordable nutrition for the people
feed the world and save the planet and
then no pressure why not no pressure on
you let me um
i'm going to put this question to you
ash but perhaps also maybe vicky you
want to come in on it as well um
question from natalie mcguire from
welcome to yorkshire natalie are you out
there
just hold on a moment we'll bring the
microphone round to you
it's about um the way in which
government
should be trying to get involved here
yeah i was listening to a really
interesting debate this morning on the
radio actually driving through around
whether financial incentives should be
used for
uh organizations that are proactively
working towards their kind of green
commitments and financial deterrence for
those that aren't working and the debate
was actually around kind of oil
refineries and the production of methane
gas where i appreciate that's not
specific for yorkshire but it does raise
the question as to whether we should be
focusing on incentives or deterrence or
both um in these kind of circumstances
is it time for radical change
what do you think ash
well i i think it's it's something that
we are constantly having to uh consider
when it comes to our farmers because
they they both own the business but rely
on us as management to advise them how
to run the business we we think it's a
combination of both actually uh
incentivizing but also having sort of
policies or regulation in place that
drives behavior i think ultimately what
we're interested in is what drives the
behavioral change and for a sustained
period
so so that's how we uh and ultimately
what we're interested in is can we back
up the changes that we want to make with
the science
so what so what we're we're concerned
about is quite often the debate when it
comes to climate change and action is
quite emotive in nature and therefore
where we would like to instead of debate
more is a much more science objective uh
uh set of sort of change programs um
that would be our take on it vicky
yes
i agree with that but it sort of links
in with the
links to the earlier question that was
asked about you know what do you do with
all these smes and how do you help them
uh and indeed i think being able to
monitor your carbon footprint is quite
important so you need to have the data
to be able to do it and know therefore
you need to do in terms of improving uh
the situation that
does require some investment and maybe
that investment can come from the big
firms that
use you as as part of the supply chain
for example
um
one of the problems of course is that
right now because companies are trying
to reduce their costs big companies as
well
they're cutting down their supply chain
quite significantly and in fact are
probably expecting the supply chain to
bear a lot of the cost instead of
anything that's going on right now so
let's hope that this doesn't last for
very long and therefore we convert
something you know slightly more
beneficial for smes than where we are
right this minute but digitalization is
is absolutely essential in terms of
being able to to get the data that that
you need and of course it also allows
you to do a lot in relation to energy
efficiency but in terms of of carrots
and sticks that can be offered more
generally of course
um the big firms will
be able to incentivize the smaller firms
and suppliers if they say we're only
going to be buying if you do those
various things but the supplier can also
help you make sure that you do that
so you can be
quite environmentally conscious and do
the right things and therefore you have
a seat at the table if you like in the
sense of being part of a supply chain
but they can also be tax incentives
the type of incentives that mean that if
you do do those things in a certain way
then you can get some tax credits
perhaps particularly for sm would matter
hugely and then you can also involve
people who decide on procurement to buy
from firms that do the right thing but
again you have to assume that there is a
capacity for those companies to do that
and as you move further down the the
size then you immediately hit the
problems of can you actually afford it
or do you just go out of business
basically so it's it's a big dilemma and
i think again
uh there needs to be a lot more working
across i think it's interesting when you
look at other countries and the way in
which they manage the supply chain
you know in germany for example the big
firms really support the supply chain
including with loans and so on it's been
happening for a long period of time it
used to happen here as well but that
sort of stopped so there is much more of
a of an industry structure that that
supports that development to take place
we don't quite have that and maybe we
need to go back to to doing so because
otherwise we will lose that ability to
to have a vibrant sme sector which after
all employs
the vast majority of the people in this
country
all right uh natalie i hope that
answered your question i want to come
back to the theme that we were on i want
to come to you diane talking about that
tension between your bottom line
and the environment you're already
making a technology um
that when we were talking to mark carney
earlier it's exactly in the sweet spot
that needs that turbo boost
of investment
which you'll get when the demand is
there for your product
talk to us about those tensions within
the shipping industry
who've hit the two been left out of the
net zero
focus haven't they but it is looming
back ahead of cop 26. it's expensive to
change the way you power big tankers
isn't it
yeah so you're absolutely right i mean
shipping was excluded from the paris
agreement and um so to your questions
point about um you know carrots and
sticks we need both
we need to have shipping included in the
net zero conversation in the zero
emissions conversation at glasgow so
it's absolutely essential that it gets
included in the glasgow accord when it
emerges
but i think what we
um what we're experiencing in real terms
so shipping is responsible for about
three or four percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions that doesn't
sound like a lot everyone says oh that's
not very much but actually all of those
not very much is adaptable it's the same
as the uk it's the same as germany's
emissions we're working our socks off
in various developed countries to try to
try and reduce those emissions but
shipping isn't motivated to do that
because it's its commitment is just to
reduce its um greenhouse gas emissions
by 50 by 2050. so that's so far in the
future
and there's no
carrots to do it that it means that we
we all kind of sit there as loads of
really brilliantly kind good people in
the industry want to do something but
the system doesn't enable it for them so
you could be scaling up your technology
if the demand was there if the shipping
industry had the certainty that they
needed to change they also needs the
certainty of seeing the technology in
action
and i think it's absolutely rational of
every single ship owner to say i want to
see that working on a real ship before i
buy it i mean i'm not going to buy a
solar panel put it on my roof
if i've not seen it working because it
might bring my house crashing down so i
think it's entirely sensible for those
people to say prove it to me die and
we'll buy it off you we want to buy it
we want to reduce our emissions because
our technology has been demonstrated to
save 20 fuel that's a cost saving you
need to see that they want to see it
they need to kick the tires before they
can do it and that's where the struggle
is to get the finance from innovation
from from invention if you like into
innovation there's a demand pool i've
got loads of letters from ship owners
saying you know build it and we will
come
but we just can't get over that
innovation hump it's a yeah
i hear the frustration with that um a
question coming from our audience from
uh ashley kemker it's a student at
manchester business school i think lindy
this this one is for you and we'll send
our microphone round to you but i think
in a nutshell we'll let you put it put
it to her yourself but it's about
what the government needs to do lindy in
order to get
the labor force suitably skilled up for
a green recovery it's all very well
saying we need to transition but how are
we going to how are we going to retrain
people to do it but actually go ahead
thanks so my question is basically that
uh the uk economy they have promised
that they would go net zero by 2050 and
in order to achieve that the companies
will have to upscale their products
their processes and along with that
their skills as well and my question is
more related to the skills aspect of it
so in your opinion what is the
government doing and what they should do
additionally
to get the skill force ready and trained
to embrace say the the future or the
green future
and that's certainly an issue which
concerns a lot of people and within um
within south yorkshire we've had
several economic shocks in that way and
people having to
transition into new employment from
mining from steel
and other aspects of heavy industry and
you're right that we need people that
that transition needs to be fair and
people need to be prepared for it both
people who are currently in work but
also
uh young people who will be joining the
workforce over over the next years and
indeed decades and
although it's not a particular area that
friends of the earth is campaigning on
other organizations such as green new
deals certainly have been working a lot
in in that way and a key argument is we
need to get the training right we need
to prepare young people who are moving
into the workforce for the jobs of the
future and not to prepare them for the
jobs that were in the past or indeed the
jobs that um that that are already gone
but people think are still are going to
be available to them um obviously many
of the skills can be applied elsewhere
the heavy industry skills that were
developed here are often now being
applied within the advanced
manufacturing um
area in in on the brotherhood sheffield
border and that that facility and those
skills are being put to good use there
although obviously another issue is that
we actually need a far smaller workforce
in that way but engineering skills could
be transferred other skills need to be
developed and again it's about
investment somebody mentioned earlier on
the importance of education and my own
background was in education and i
recognise that that is crucially
important both in educating the public
around what the crap how the crisis is
is emerging how it is developing the
seriousness of it but also in how we can
cope how we can do things differently
how we can be trained up to work in a
different way so yes you're right that
those things can be done but they'll
only be done with support from outside
because it is not necessarily in the
interests of any current industries to
be training people up in work that they
may or may not want them to be doing in
the future so there has to be external
support for that and that has to come
from the government
i want to come to another question there
that's come to us from the audience uh
rashad were you
out there somewhere
yes there you are um about the
accountability of net zero commitments
who's keeping track didn't put it to our
panel thank you uh
we have accountants who are tracking the
impact of net zero carbon and we have
companies who are making a plan how to
reduce it but then who is actually
keeping a track
of
how we are spending the money and even
if we are going in the right direction
and do we have time and resources that
if there's a possible downside
to the entire scenario
do we have time and money to
come back
and build this
so i suppose the question is touching on
really to what extent are pledges
genuine to what extent are they green
washing who's even keeping track brief
word from the olympia i have no idea
who's keeping track but i am
fairly confident that there's an awful
lot of green washing going on i was
fascinated by the um the graphic that
was put up earlier about the the way in
which companies have been making
promises and have been committing to
things and can be shown to be doing
taking action and reducing emissions and
that is much less true of um of working
at government level
and that is definitely something that
needs to be taken account of more it's
very easy to talk it's very easy to make
promises and pledges and say we're going
to do these wonderful things we know
that it is harder to do the next step
and nobody's going to say that that's
easy but definitely the steps need to be
taken and it's not enough to come up
with a great big you know plan and a
promise without actually having a
delivery a delivery plan behind that
and the commitments that have been made
in the exhortations that have been made
are insufficient and this is i'm sure
we're going to get onto cop 26 but
um you know that is the the big issue
around cop 26 that so many promises are
going to be made and it's going to be
glitzy and and glamorous and you know on
the tv all the time and people are going
to get credit for great big
announcements but actually there's a lot
of work that needs to be done behind
that and sometimes the glitz and the
glamour and the announcements can
actually uh distract from the fact that
very little is going on we'll we'll come
on we'll finish actually by talking
about our hopes and fears for cop 26.
but ashley just want to come
back to you on that very question i mean
your pledge to cut emissions by 30 by
2030 who keeps track of that
so we we follow a science-based uh
target system where it's audited uh by
accountants as you talk about as well
and i think the key thing for us is some
of our pledges are not as far-reaching
as other people in the industry but we
have had years of taking action and
delivering on our promises and what
that's taught us
is actually it's very important to make
far-reaching commitments so we think
that's important because it
it talks about the aspiration the
leadership behind it but it's how you
follow up on it so i think measurement
is really important commitment at
operational level
as well as at leadership level and then
being very clear on the programs that
drive improvement whether it's on farm
in factory or actually in the way that
we move products
so actually for for us we spend much
more energy and how do we bring things
to life in reality
than the pledges
that we make and the way that we do that
is in the way that we follow up on data
so our data collection not only on on
farm for instance is is annual and every
year we publish
uh in a transparent way the summary of
all of those results but what we also do
is we individually share that with our
farmers
so in an anonymized way that they can
then see how they compare to the average
farmer and so on and see where they can
improve so for me it's very much about
being able to measure have programs just
one thing that diane said that i thought
was a really really important point to
pick up on and the role of government as
well
is quite often in the early days there
is that balance in terms of cost versus
investment does it pay off but that can
often
be improved by being able to scale the
idea so i think for me scaling is also
really important and therefore
government can really
play a hand there in terms of
inter-industry collaboration to be able
to really scale some of these ideas so
they aren't an economic kind of negative
uh for people to make the the
investments
really interesting
final word really from each of you about
um
i mean you sound a little skeptical
lindy if you don't mind me saying about
what we might get out of cop 26. so how
are you feeling about it vicky and what
are you going to be looking for
specifically
there's so much that's been said before
the actual meeting so the expectations
have have varied there's some who are
quite optimistic about it bringing loads
of commitments together and others who
think that it would be a little bit like
before when uh all sorts of pleasures
were made and they weren't uh followed
and i think the example of the latter
is um to do with transferring money to
developing countries which absolutely
need to adapt and also
um have some technology transfer which
is absolutely essential and it was that
money that 100 billion a year was
pledged in 2009 wasn't it exactly and
here we are and very little is being
dispatched every year and now they said
they'd do it because everyone's been
also doubling or increasing the amount
that they had pledged originally but of
course very little of that money had
ever gone
so that's the real worry about coming up
with loads of commitments which sound
good but perhaps don't
take account of the reality in the short
term and they don't take account of the
transition period that is required to
get to where you want to be and all
those
sticks and carrots that are absolutely
essential
at the end of the day i'm afraid it
comes to regulation whether it's
shipping or anywhere else and money and
if that money isn't available
taking risks with technology
really you know spreading that risk as
well making sure all the stuff we've
just been hearing about in terms of
being able to scale up for example
carbon capture and storage
it's still being tried there are a
number of possibilities that will be
decided pretty quickly in the uk as well
it's been going on for decades that type
of discussion
and and we're still not really there so
uh it just takes too long to make those
decisions and too little money is
actually being spent and if you just
look at what is required between now and
2030 of course cop236 is going to be
looking at the ultimate you know
temperature increase and and really you
know looking at all the evidence science
that we've just been talking about um
which is saying that we we're nearly
there already in terms of the 1.5
centigrade increase and we've already
are at 1.1 nothing 1.2 so there really
isn't very much time so it's crucial
what happens between now and 2030 and
that amount of money is now being
recalculated in terms of what is needed
so
just the the european union is saying
that what they need to be spending is
360 billion a year between now and 2030
and 125 billion
of
digitalization which is absolutely
essential now you know i mentioned
earlier that they're putting out the
first bond for 20 billion well that's
very very little by comparison to what
is actually needed and i think it's the
ambition that has to be there and has to
be if you like
measured and monitored
in terms of how they do from here on it
starts the ball rolling
but it shouldn't start the ball rolling
it's it should just push it further i
mean the the ball should really have
been starting a while ago a long time
ago yeah yeah and a word from you lindy
about what you're hoping to see
it's a great opportunity here in the uk
that um that glasgow is the host for
cop26 and um and i know that there's
plenty of opportunity for the uk to be
making its own promises and
announcements a huge concern though and
it links with with um uh with something
that both vicky and um and diane said is
that at the same time we are in the uk
have not um
we are still looking at developing a
massive oil field west of shetland the
cambo oil field and this will be
equivalent in its emissions to 18 coal
fired power stations it's also going to
be vastly expensive so um blackrock who
you mentioned is having you know
billions of
dollars available for investment are one
of the key players in thinking that they
will invest within cambo
um so you have a bit of a perfect storm
there of lots of money that could be
spent in other ways being spent on uh
exploiting fossil fuels now the
government have the opportunity to say
no this can't this can't happen we are
not going to allow the exploitation in
that way because at the moment there's a
huge degree of hypocrisy insisting on
other countries doing their bit when
we're not taking those sort of stands
ourselves there is money available both
in the private sector and indeed the
public sector because as diane pointed
out we are um just about the the the
country with the most favorable regime
in terms of
tax credits and an actual
funding support
and subsidies for fossil fuels
and lots of oil and gas companies want
to be based here but we need to address
that because the money is there to do
the sort of things which are needed to
be done
and they need to be done very quickly so
we're hoping that the uk will take a
stand that um
ensures that we haven't got long to wait
diana had wanted to come to you for a
final word from you about what you hope
to get out of cop 26 but i'm being told
that we are all out of time i'm afraid
unless you could do it in one sentence
so yes repurposing oil and gas workers
through a series of events that we're
doing at malin which is just opposite
cop 26 where we're bringing the whole
shipping industry together
to create an action plan through um the
the oil and gas sector transferring
their knowledge and expertise into green
power for shipping that's what we want
to do at cop26 and that's what we're
doing okay all right uh we are out of
time i hope you enjoyed that panel
discussion uh got through as much as we
could there there's so much obviously
that we could still talk about i'm going
to give you all a 15-minute comfort
break now and when you come back trevor
phillips is going to be hosting a panel
all about the leveling up agenda so we
hope to see you back for that
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome back to the
face of steel here in the former temple
borough steelworks in rotherham
we're here today for big ideas live a
new format for sky news in which we take
time to explore big issues and big ideas
if there is a big idea that the
government would like us to be thinking
about today it is leveling up
but as ian king pointed out in a session
this morning
what it means in practice is still to
become entirely clear
some of my own family who live in
sheffield
who
uh work in nottingham as well never tire
of telling me that there's a vast
deafening uh sucking sound common across
the north and they say that's the sound
of power
money and jobs being sucked from the
regions into london
well they love where they live and they
think they have a better environment
better quality of life than in the overs
heated south but every time something
goes wrong they tell me covid
fuel shortages uh the threat of
inflation or indeed stagflation we're
not talking about
they feel that they're going to be hit
first
and hit harder
well yesterday the former deputy prime
minister michael hesseltine uh speaking
here on sky news offered his own big
idea to me and he said that the
government needed to devolve power to
accountable leaders named elected
leaders in the regions because they know
what's needed
so is that the answer or would that just
mean more fragmentation of the nation
can the identity and pride felt by many
communities
across the north of england helped to
drive economic growth
i'll be discussing that with a panel of
experts in a moment but first our
business correspondent helen and smith
is here
to set the scene
hello nan thanks trevor and afternoon
again everyone so we've heard so much
about levelling up over the last year or
so haven't we not just from those who
propose it but also from those who
protest they don't really know what it
means and historically there's been a
lot written and a lot said about the
inequalities between north and south but
at this very moment that we're at now
post pandemic what are the challenges
and the opportunities as well to getting
this country well and truly leveled so
first of all where are we at i want to
address head-on that notion that the
north routinely gets less spent on it
than the south is that true so take a
look at this firstly i want you to pay
attention only to how high up the blobs
are on this graph first what we've
charted along this axis here is the
total spend uh per head in each region
of the country by the government in 2020
so total look london up there at the top
uh is the most but look the northeast
and the northwest actually come in
second and third however total spend
doesn't really give us the whole picture
because total spend includes things like
nhs salaries and benefits and money that
sort of is there and then it's gone so
what we've plotted along at the axis at
the bottom is total investment spend
for each region of the country uh
investments been going into
infrastructure and things like that and
as you can see a slightly different
story again london out there at the the
far end southeast coming second but and
although the north west not so bad the
northeast yorkshire in the humber much
further over towards here so a very
different story now crucially this is
just a moment in time this is just 2020
and of course what happens over time
incredibly important as well so what
we've charted here is the growth in
investment spend since 2016. 2016 of
course you remember just shortly after
we very first heard about the northern
powerhouse actually you can see up in
the top there the green line is the west
midlands that has had its spend grow the
most in terms of investment that's
likely a lot to do with hs2 but the
southeast coming in second there and
crucially i just want to draw your
attention to the yellow line at the
bottom yorkshire and the humber where we
currently are really one of the only
regions in the country where spend
really declined over that period peaking
just about to what it was in 2016 very
very recently there now look in terms of
regional recovery and regional
prosperity it's not just what the
government is doing that matters but
it's also what we as consumers are doing
and how we're behaving so what we've
charted here is footfall uh football
recovery in cities around the country
since the pandemic compared to
pre-pandemic levels for obvious reasons
we haven't been able to put every single
one on there could be a lot but i've
just picked out a few that i think tell
interesting stories firstly the two at
the top blackpool south end it's worth
saying there are only four cities in
four cities and towns in the whole
country where footfall is now recovered
to what it was before the pandemic or
indeed exceeding it they're all seaside
and touristy towns down at the bottom
there london sheffield that big story of
city centres just really struggling to
recover in terms of their footfall and
then in the orange barnsley we've put
that on there because there's a really
interesting story around some of these
sort of smaller regional residential
towns actually some that historically
have been a little more deprived some of
the footfall and the spenders recovered
much much better there than in other
places that's partly uh because of it's
more it's more residential people live
there and also because a lot of the
businesses in those places are more
likely to be essential so people need to
get back there for their essential spend
it matters as well what business is
doing of course the number of companies
the number of jobs the amount of
employment what we've shown you here is
the growth in the number of companies in
each region of the country since 2010 so
since that financial crisis and look
it's really clear isn't it london the
south east the south west it is still
those regions that have by far the
biggest growth in the number of
companies and we know that there's
well-documented problems with qualified
people sometimes choosing to leave
to travel south particularly to the
capital for work and very finally i want
to leave you with this this is
incidentally my favorite chart of the
day and i think it gives a slightly
quirky look into some of the problems we
face this shows the inequality of
broadband connectivity in different
countries across the world so the red
blobs the least connected region in each
country the green blobs the most
connected region in each country
essentially what this is showing us is
that we have a greater inequality of
connectivity in this country than
colombia has certainly a greater
inequality of connectivity than denmark
has and look our worst connected region
the northeast there is by far worse off
than the vast majority of all these
other countries the u.s france spain
worth saying the same picture plays out
when you look at germany italy portugal
so i hope this gives a bit of a sense of
just how much there is to do and just
how multi-faceted the problems are if we
really want to get this country well and
truly leveled up thank you trevor hello
nan thank you very much indeed some
striking grasp there i'm i'm i'm mildly
disturbed by the the uh idea that it's
easier to watch us in colombia than it
is uh in gateshead uh right now um but
let's uh come actually we'll come to the
son of gate's head in a moment because
i'm joined by a
group of experts
who are going to discuss what the north
needs from government and what indeed
the north might do for itself today
uh chris greene is the conservative mp
for bolton west and atherton
simon rush is the founder of northern
power women and northern power futures
charles edward is the vice chancellor of
leeds trinity university
and sebastian payne the aforesaid son of
gateshead is the author of broken
heartland a journey through labour's
lost england just out this week
now let's let's start
by looking
forward let's let's talk about
opportunities they say we should never
let a crisis go to waste
at conway this morning identified four
crises that we're in the middle of labor
uh distribution materials and so on
simone is there an opportunity for the
north in this crisis um i think we're
always going to look at an opportunity
when we set out
at the start of the pandemic is what can
we do and i think our focus has always
been about what can we do we know
there's lots of barriers there we know
there's lots of inequality we know
there's lots of hurdles but from the the
campaign and the movement that i created
which is about accelerating gender
equality and social mobility from the
north it's very much looking about that
we can approach and so at the start of
the pandemic like what can we do what
can we do the first thing was to check
in on people was to check in how we're
going to wrap an arm around these senior
business leaders doing amazing you know
making these you know um
history-making uh decisions every day
and also to checking on those at the
start of their career who think actually
what an earth is ahead of me how on
earth are we going to navigate what's a
head so what we did when we set out um
at the start of this is we we documented
as we went along and a year ago we we
created a leveling up report but it was
our level leveling up by powering on be
i'm very much about looking at the
opportunities as you say trevor and the
positive thing that came out and looking
at the some of the good stuff that
happened and i think that's what we have
to do at times because there's certain
things that we can't do but actually
what can we do and i think there's a
there's a company one of the the reports
recently is one of our northern powerman
community a company in leeds just not
too far up the way has had a thirty
percent growth it's a small uh pan
intelligence uh software development
company but they have 30 growth and
they've done that because of the lack of
geographical barriers and the lack and
the
impetus around flexible work which we
haven't had before okay charles um
you're in if you like the intellectual
industry do you think uh that what we're
seeing is simone's saying is a situation
in which
there's a new opportunity created by
in a way destruction of geography
there will always be opportunities uh i
think the question is providing the
appropriate and conducive environment to
be able to harness those opportunities
if i give you an example from the leak
city region where
i reside at the moment we have
380 000 people or 26 percent of the
adult population that have no
qualifications or very low skills there
must be something in in that resource
pool
which we call the uh
tapping
if you look at how the world is changing
around us and you look at what we need
to do around um the construction
industry uh to help us with the issue of
sustainability especially in our homes
uh there's this suggestion that 70
percent of all the houses we need for
the next 30 years have been built
already it's what do we do to convert
and modernize them to make sure they are
habitable and meet the energy use so
there's something to be done
around that there's something to be done
around the transportation uh as part of
supporting us enriching
the carbon neutrality but i think we
need to ask ourselves the question
in the policy we put forward in the
legislation and regulation how do we
create an environment for businesses for
the young people give them the
confidence to think about tomorrow and
then the future so there is
opportunities but we have to harness
that very very uh quietly and
confidently chris green um well we've
heard two examples of of opportunities
can um
can the north realize those
opportunities on its own or does it need
something from
the wider nation and from government
well um the north is part of the united
kingdom so it's got to be a joint effort
i'm looking forward to later this year
for the government to produce its white
paper on leveling up we have a strong
sense of what it ought to mean
lisa many commentators and people
looking in have a strong sense of what
it ought to be and i think a key aspect
is when we look at the city of london
and the wider southeast what's one of
its great qualities transport if someone
wants to locate a business in the
southeast of england you know your pool
of talent is immense
we need the north of england to have
that pool of talent and how do we get
that pool of talent for any business
wanting to locate here it's by having
far better network uh communications
whether it's public transport or
motorways and railways we need to sort
these things out but the second point is
focused on education it needs to go hand
in hand with transport infrastructure
there was a report from the children's
commissioner about three years ago
growing up north and it showed london
which
in 2004 was way behind the north of
england now is way ahead of the north of
england
we've got to have that focus in the
north of england on education if we get
these things at the same time the talent
we create in the north will get jobs in
the north and we create our own
prosperity and actually we choose what
businesses what industries we want to
champion
but better transport and better
education are
desirable everywhere aren't there i mean
is there anything special about what one
would do in the north well it's basic
things so on the one hand we
are talking great deal at the moment
with uh hs2
and you look at hs2 which is
fundamentally about a road link to
london
and it's very different link to london
that's our rail link yes a rail link
to london and you look at people getting
the railways between manchester and
liverpool it's very difficult they're
only 30 35 miles apart it's very
difficult at the moment and we need that
[Music]
northern power rail a proper vision for
what that's going to be and when that's
going to be delivered so businesses know
this is the time to invest and we really
get motoring or on the track
sebastian playing you've been um
conducting or doing a tour of northern
cities um in your own
rather exotic mode of transport you can
tell us about um
how are you seeing it do you think
that we're in a situation where there
could be a renaissance uh of
of the north and if so what would it
look like
well it's fainting we're talking about
this here because i'm sitting and you
can see on a steel beam directly up
there it says labor support strikes vote
scargill so i think that is a slogan
from a slightly different political age
in this building probably not the place
to start no
the renaissance but i think this is
actually an example of how the north has
changed in a way many people haven't
quite recognized it because when people
have looked at many parts of the country
that voted for brexit and voted for
conservative for the first time in 2019
that's the evil they think of they think
of an industrial era that's in decline
not places that have gone through a lot
of change and a lot of renewal since
de-industrialization and one the place i
visited in broken heartlands is concert
again a great steel town in the
northeast of england that edits prime
employed 6 000 steel workers that closed
in 1980 unemployment hit 36 percent at
its peak and that went through a lot of
pain but if you look where it is now
it's got many new businesses private
housing and crucially a more diversified
economic base so in some ways there's
many things to be hopeful about that
these police are not stuck in the past
in my view they're not looking backwards
they are optimistic about the future but
to come some of the points that chris
was making there is a long term under
investment particularly on transport
particularly on infrastructure so that's
why i think it deserves particular focus
from this government there but i think
it's not just about money though it is
about structural form and this is when
lord michael hesseltown is completely
right on mayors and power that you're
not going to make these places better
from whitehall it has to be done with
good strong local leaders so if you look
in south yorkshire you've had dan jarvis
or van gaal in the teas valley they have
bought enacted chains so we need more
mayors with more powers we need to make
up for that historic under investment
transport and skills as well is
completely crucial in some ways the
solution is not that difficult to make
the north better the key thing is
delivery and doing it and making it
happen just so i'm going to come to some
question uh comment i think we've got
from the audience before i do that
charles this is your skills um ed conway
in a
blizzard of in interesting charts today
one of the ones that was i thought most
significant was that he showed that
every country has a skills mismatch that
is to say if you ask people
have you got the skills to do the thing
that the job you're currently doing um
in germany about 20
are essentially in the wrong job
in this country it's more like 40
percent
do you think that there is an issue with
our capability
uh of
of getting the right people to be able
to do the right job to
to essentially rebound from where we've
been in the last 18 months two years
it's interesting trevor the issue is
both skill shortages and skills gap i
think the point you were making natalie
was the skills gap yeah in other words
those who
required particular sets of skills for
the jobs they need that quality of skill
is not there i have to say the issue
have been going on well before brexit
well before i covet it just got slightly
worse
i remember many many years ago when i
was a student
of construction about 30 years ago and i
know you do have what is called direct
labor supply
where
a particular company trains up their own
staff
and not a wait to get the staff from
supply chains but those areas are gone i
think it's a mixture of us having
policies that are consistent and
sustained we've had the towing and
throwing where the government at times
is finger-pointed asking you haven't
invested and the employer turned around
to say
we can't invest because the environment
is not conducive so the issue the issue
becomes we all need to know that this is
joined up the employer has a role to
play the government has the role to play
now they say the university which i'm
part of has a role to play to make sure
we look at skills for today and skills
for tomorrow we're going to come back to
this issue of coordination let me go to
hashem in our audience
hashim i think you had a comment on this
issue
yeah so i want to say it's been reported
recently that the disparity in
productivity
and economic output per capita between
parts of the north and the southeast is
in relative terms as large as it was
between east germany and west germany
before reunification it took decades and
trillions to narrow that gap so i think
that demonstrates that leveling up must
go beyond electoral cycles it's not just
about the amount of money that we spend
but importantly about where we spend it
and crucially it can't be achieved by
central government alone so i wanted to
ask what can be done to create an
environment which attracts more private
sector investment and what role does
ambitious regional mayors that you've
mentioned sebastian play in supporting
that well actually um
let's do let's make that
almost literally concrete and take a
case in point which is transport andrew
mcphillips i think has a question on
exactly that
uh that issue andrew
yeah thanks um new research published by
macdonald today shows that northern
powerhouse rail could have a greater
economic impact than the government's
own figures even suggest
does the panel agree that a new line
linking the cities of the north and
which is also reliant on hs2 being
delivered in full is a project which if
cancelled leaves leveling up as nothing
more than a broken promise you're
addressing this a moment ago chris uh do
you agree that scrapping it would be a
broken promise and
tie that if you would to hashim's point
about how we actually
coordinate how we make thing bring this
all together
rather being a series of projects i
think we ought to be cautious about
bringing it together too much because
you have to leave that opportunity and
perspective from the private sector to
think these are the opportunities we
have
i do think to a significant extent uh
that the north of england when you're
looking at globalization when you're
looking at other specialties in the
united kingdom you look at the golden
triangle you look at the
financial uh specialization in london
you look at different parts of the
country i do believe that north of
england uh and manufacturing do go
together uh very well so the government
has to set a vision that enables
manufacturing you've got to have better
transport obviously
hs2 is often seen as a route down to
london and one of the disappointing
facts was that
northern power rail
was dependent upon hs2 being completed
for the railway stations whether it's in
leeds or in manchester to cut across so
we have to find out very quickly i think
to give people confidence what's going
to happen
with that eastern leg up to leads on hs2
and if that does go that there is a
railway station uh that's going to be
put in place for northern power rail
which needs to be get going uh very soon
so there's a huge what is mr the
secretary of transport saying saying to
you uh the minister responsible for the
northern powerhouse uh as well uh so at
the moment
um i i think they're looking up uh
looking forward to the publication of
the
uh leveling up white paper i think
there's a lot of stuff to come from uh
michael gove as well who's just been
appointed and responsible for devolution
as well so i think there's a great deal
of work and ultimately uh the person we
need to be focused on
uh is uh the chancellor at the spending
review and the budget later this month
where these announcements ought to be
made so it all comes down to rishi it
does
shimon i think collaboration is key you
talked about the the roles that the
mayors have to play and i've seen
there's clearly a connectivity between
andy burnham and steven they will
naturally play nice but i've seen that
cross mare collaboration and coming
together and there's been just recently
only a couple of weeks ago there's been
the new pandemic institute that was
launched in liverpool and that was done
almost through a series of bringing
together almost the impossible how do
you bring academia how do you bring
healthcare how do you bring government
how do you bring um global investor into
a city to create jobs to create this you
know so i think there's examples there
but i think there's there's elements of
have to collaborate i have to play nice
and i think when it comes to some of
that
those big decisions as well it's having
the right people at the table we've
talked about skills we've talked about
skills all day where are those those
decisions that are being made about
those
whether it be young people whether it be
people underrepresented communities need
to be at the table when we're actually
allocating or making these decisions as
well is key before we leave the topic of
rail um i i don't want uh uh you know
the soft toughness i don't want anybody
to to leave this thinking that the north
is just a place where everybody is
exactly the same i suspect that there
are people who think that there are
imbalances here alison matthews i think
has a point on this in relation to
uh transport allison
um i think we're going to get a
microphone to you and it's with you now
hey yeah so i was just seeing um that
the north isn't manchester and liverpool
if you kind of guess by my accent i'm
not far from concert woohoo
and and i feel like durham and newcastle
really get forgotten about and it's not
just when it comes to transport it's a
lot of things when you talk about the
north when government talk about the
north tends to be manchester liverpool
leeds and the northeast really does get
forgotten about are we going to get
included in things
um
seb i i talked to
your king the king of the north um
andy burnham uh ten days ago and uh i he
he has he wants transport links and so
on and uh he was
quite cross at the suggestion that what
what he's putting forward
would benefit
central manchester or indeed central
leads do you think though that there is
an issue
about
how you construct
change and particularly how construct a
transport network
that might end up with some bits of the
north doing well
but the bits of the north that really
need help
being
where they've always been
at the back of the queue i think this is
the key thing about northern powerhouse
rail that chris was talking about and if
you look at the lens of this is a new
railway between liverpool and leeds then
if you live in dublin more concert then
you're going to say well how does this
actually help me but of course by
building that there are many other
places along the way and that's why
we'll have to see what's in the northern
powerhouse rail plan before we can see
what it's going to do there but to take
the example of high speed 2 railway
which i think will still happen in some
form you create that for the new
intercity links but the other the
existing west coast mainline is there
and is freed up to allow much greater
links to milton keynes to crew to many
of the other small places that often
don't get forgotten on the way so i
think you can do both in this but i
think there is a really crucial identity
question we mentioned the northeast here
and you know there is a north of time
melody at the moment which to me is
completely mad when there is a clear
economic unit in tyneside that includes
newcastle gates there dumb sun and what
have you you could create a conurbation
around that why did that not exist
because all the local council leaders
were arguing and they wouldn't do a deal
with each other so sometimes problems of
these things are founded locally due to
local rivals due to people's feelings
about each other if you don't mind me
trevor trying to come back on a point
that was made earlier about
business investment i think that is
actually very key here because yes you
can pour money into transport yes you
can make up for decades of under
investment but to get a sustainable
economy in the places that have
struggled you've got to make an
appetizing business environments and i
think there's obviously the government
are looking at free ports you've got
questions about enterprise zones things
you can do to encourage business
investment so when that white paper
comes out later this month that's
actually what i'm most interested in
because it's easy to pour money into
things but you can only do that so many
times and that doesn't create a
sustainable economic base when you hit
the next downturn and public spending
eventually gets cut back and if you look
at the example of liverpool when it was
regenerated um in the 1980s and 1990s
that was based on public private
partnerships i think that has to be
really key to this if you're going to
make it not just a one-off hit
um jackie freeborn i think has raised
this point about public uh
public-private partnerships and to the
extent to which they are important i
wonder if we could come to jackie in a
moment um
uh there you are
uh we will get a microphone to you now
jackie oh hi hi um yeah my question is
exactly about that because i think we've
seen some great examples of where public
and private come together to solve
problems but it doesn't work all the
time and i'm just wondering whether we
need some sort of institute of
enlightened leadership and collaboration
so we can learn from those best examples
and put it into practice at
a local level local politics always get
in the way always do it's just the
nature of it is but businesses and
public sector are very different in the
way that they make decisions the way
that they have to be accountable and i'm
just wondering how do we capture the
best of that and roll it out to places
and make sure it becomes an intricate
part of the economy and what we do to
actually regenerate places
charles you run a big public sector out
there to university and um
you presumably sit at the center of
a kind of collaboration how did it work
and does it work actually in leeds
that's that's a very very good question
and a good question from jackie
i had a university like trinity
university we work with over 3 000
businesses
and we take pride in in saying that all
our students are the undergraduate
program have placement the only
university that will say that all our
undergraduate and we're able to do that
because of the collaboration and the
cooperation we have with businesses just
last week i was in a meeting with the
chambers of commerce
speaking to businesses wanting to know
how
we can co-jointly offer our programs to
our students to make sure that these
students are undergoing a program so
that when they finish they're as ready
as they can with businesses so
partnership collaboration i think it's
important and i have to say there are
increasing opportunities to do that
apprenticeship it's one way
we take pride as a university to have
apprenticeship with the west yorkshire
police
and with the prison services the unlock
program and we cannot do that without
having real partnership but it's
partnership where the two
partners will have to get something and
put something uh in that
i don't think we will get real leveling
up if we don't partner and making sure
that there is trust honesty
and reciprocity in the way we partner so
it's working if it's put together well
simon do you think um that we've got the
environment that allows for that kind of
partnership one of the things that
businesses say and this is they say that
all say this all over the country not
just in the north that for example the
apprenticeship program
too difficult to bureaucratic and in
fact i think that there are several
hundred million quids worth of um
grant
sitting unused because employers
can't be bothered to go through the
all of the processes and the hoops
what's interesting actually there's a
study out from newcastle university at
newcastle college sorry earlier this
year which stated that um
now more than ever there's more uh more
places um people are looking to work and
study locally because they don't want to
be in a situation where they're having
to be away from home if a another
situation like the last 18 months arises
and i think the the rise in searches for
higher uh higher level apprenticeship
was certainly to 171 or something like
that
so i think that demand proves that
there's got to be a simple
simplification but that that's the
challenge that happens is those
decisions and how it's all made and the
route to getting it is made with you
know by the same people making the same
decisions that's why you need to bring
those people who are trying to access
this whether it be the students whether
the businesses got to bring people
together and it comes back to that
conversation again about let's bring
different people into the mix to ensure
that these things thrive there's no
point having these opportunities out
there then people there's a demand for
them 171 people searching for those
higher level apprentices but they can't
get to it so we have to change we have
to fix the system by bringing the right
people to discuss what do we need to
make it easier for people to do crack on
and and get engaged with them chris uh
is there a problem here the government
talks a good game about doing all of
this kind of thing and by the way this
is governments of all stamps but on to
take the example of the apprenticeships
actually one of the things that became
clear quite early in the apprenticeship
program is that
it worked at high level so
uh for example the the showcase example
for the apprenticeship programmers rolls
royce and derby fantastic but that's
basically degree level but actually
lower down
or at lower levels of qualification
it doesn't seem to work or the the cost
in resource and difficulty getting it to
happen is so great it's not worth it for
employers
well it's uh it's very difficult
for many organizations to make the
apprenticeship levy work corporations
can because basically organizations like
rolls-royce other large organizations
are basically doing uh this
apprenticeship approach already all they
have to do is configure what they're
already doing
uh into a format where they can draw
that money back into their organization
smaller organizations find it far more
difficult the company in my constituency
still works
they train their people they've trained
their people for decades
and it doesn't work for them and so
therefore they don't feel it's an
apprenticeship levy for reinvestment
they feel it's a tax and the government
has to be far more respectful of
organizations at whatever level and
rather than having a
an ambition which from the outside
objectively you just think this is about
a large number of apprenticeships so a
minister can say we have achieved x y or
zed it's got to be far more respectful
of different size organizations and yes
if we want to encourage large
organizations to invest in
apprenticeships that's fine but we've
got to appreciate that they're largely
already doing it okay
we've got a question from um bob jeffrey
who i think is represents the sheffield
trade trade chef world trade council
which if if i have my history right is
one of the uh
kind of fundamental organizations of the
of the trade union movement producing i
think people like david blanket if i'm
not mistaken bob second oldest in the
country after aberdeen um so yeah we at
sheffield tuc we set up a campaign in
2016 called sheffield needs pay rise
this was in response to a resolution
foundation report that showed the
sheffield city region had their highest
proportion of workers on low pay of any
city region in the uk
now associated with that we've seen very
high levels of underemployment lots of
people in zero hour contracts and part
of what our campaign is doing is trying
to fight to get better work uh terms and
conditions for workers so that
businesses particularly large businesses
aren't just taking money out of the
community while in disproportionately
employing staff on precarious contracts
now while we're coming at that from a
trade union angle there's increasing
talk of good work charters in city
regions as a mechanism to to drive up
terms and conditions and i wondered what
the panel thought of those initiatives
um so payne you probably can't move in
westminster which is your
where you normally work for some for
people going high wage high skill low
immigration let's leave the low
immigration for a moment i want to come
to that um
what can we do about the the low wage
problem that bob's talking about
well this is not something new we should
say by the way that this is you about
wages and skills we've been trying to
fix in this country pretty much ever
since the second world war and we've
tried various schemes of just putting
more money in without the productivity
gains and we saw inflation that resulted
from that we've tried various skills and
apprenticeships and i think we are on a
much better track now than we have been
ever before about that and look the
johnson government is having a very good
push at this by keeping those migration
levels low and hoping that that will
naturally result in the labor market
increasing wages and that does seem to
be happening whether that's happening at
a sustainable rate that's going to not
result in big economic bubbles in the
coming months is yet to be seen there
but i think fundamentally it's that site
you were talking about earlier trevor in
terms of the gal people in the right
jobs and the heat between moving between
you know where we were and where we're
heading and i think when you look at the
kona virus pandemic it has exposed so
much of stuff that was already there but
below the surface many zombie companies
that were based on you know very cheap
labor very low skilled labor and very
tight profit margins they've been wiped
out by the pandemic and i don't think
anyone fully knows the answer to this
because what we're trying to do in this
country i don't think it's ever been
done in such a short space of time so
quickly you know if boyce johnson said i
wanted to do this in 18 months you could
see a way of going towards that and it
could be a gradual process unless they
um pull back on not um allowing more
skilled people in through the visas
program then we're gonna try and do this
for a very short quick period of time
and i think we eventually see how the
public feels about this because we can
see the disruptions in hgv drivers in
terms of co2 and food production they
will eventually ease because the labor
market will kill trout and they will get
higher wages but the disruption to get
there is going to be really quite
significant so
it's like a shortcut to try and do
something we've been trying to do for
decades
so one um
when we think about uh in
the industrial north and wages and all
the rest of it i think that the image
that comes to mind is usually
blokes in overalls in places like this
but actually low wages
are more characteristically
uh
associated with female employment and to
some extent public service employment
can we actually do anything about that
without the the kinds of consequences
that seb's talking about which is we
throw money at it inflation rages and
then we go back to square one i think
we're at a sliding doors moment i think
what um we've seen in the last 18 months
is flexibility
that has never been afforded to
particularly those who are in low paid
um and also in those caregiving roles as
well you know that the amount of money
is billions of pounds on the economy
that is that unpaid work economy but
that opportunity that has that
should not i don't subscribe to build
that better i subscribe to build forward
better because i think you know it's not
about just taking or we'll just go back
to the way it was i think it is the
sliding doors and i think we have to
take
the opportunities around this
flexibility because otherwise we're
going to see um we're going to revert
back to like in 1950s britain if we're
not careful if so if the if we've got
organizations going to change oh we
can't do with that anymore you've all
got to be in the office we can't do this
we don't know what's around the corner i
think it's a i think someone i was
talking to last week was like you know
this is the worst worst time to be
making a big decision at the moment
because we don't know quite where we are
so i think we have to be careful that we
don't we want to go forward better but
we are a sliding doors we cannot go back
to women at home and and the low pay
jobs and you know
going into those very very sort of very
stereotypical offices we have to take
the opportunities and this is where the
forward thinking employers and small
businesses can set that culture and
there's a study by and young earlier
this year that you know um half of
people would leave their jobs um if if
it wasn't a purpose-led um you know
employer if they didn't have that
opportunity and i think were flexibility
it was always it was always a wage and
salary expectations purpose is now more
important um for those people on that
career track chris um
the
you know the prime minister who's
cheerful sort of bloke um constantly
holds out the sunlit upland
high wage high skills better better all
that um
but as seb was saying
it's not a
nice straight gradient from here to
there
and we might find ourselves in a place
where
actually what we have is
um
a very tricky labor market not rising
wages um this could be a political
catastrophe
for the government couldn't it
well we're in a very difficult situation
the pandemic has had a massive impact
and we can't take that out of the
equation so how do we
get our recovery going the more we
impose one business and i'm sure this
won't be uh what gentleman would like to
hear the more we impose upon business
the more challenges they will face in
trying to create that business and if we
remove competitive advantage from
certain areas you won't get that
business in the first place and what we
need to see the businesses locating in
sheffield in uh many northern towns and
cities
and build upon that because it's going
to take years for improvements in
education improvements and transport
improvements in other areas of our lives
when we're trying to recover and level
up it's going to take a very long time
but we need to get the jobs now in the
coming days weeks and months so imposing
and how does that happen
how does that happen uh
with the spending review i want to see
some pretty positive and with the budget
uh a pretty positive ambition i want to
see uh clear details in the white paper
for levelling up setting out exactly
what we're going to do how we're going
to do it and we might be talking about
brexit at some point but one of the
aspects of brexit is
how do we
be more flexible in our interpretation
and use of
laws that impact uh business so for
example the
uh agritech business is pretty much dead
in europe it's booming in america it's
booming in other places now that with
outside the european union how much can
we focus on agritech biotech other
businesses and industries which are
coming down the line which are here
already that we can use a competitive
advantage let me ask a couple questions
you you
so there's something i wanted to quickly
come back on there if you don't mind
which is that technology is very crucial
to all this as well that many industries
you mentioned agriculture all going
through a great wave of automation that
is going to be key but i don't think you
can rely on that to make up for the gaps
within the labor market you've got to be
very careful about this that technology
is coming you need to be ready and to
adapt to it and to get crucially those
productivity gains you don't
automatically get with higher wages but
you can't wholly rely on it that in fact
is exactly the point i wanted to come to
there is a labor market problem isn't
there that we aren't necessarily
we don't necessarily have
the right
people with the right skills in the
right place
what would you say
if
one of the things that regions could
control as they do for example in canada
is immigration
canadian provinces
have a certain number of visas which
they are allowed to issue because to
meet their needs now
would there be any mileage at all in
north or parts of north being able to
seek out the right talents wherever they
happen to be in the world what do you
think so i think the idea you could
allow certain regions to have visa
schemes i think is one that is
definitely worth examining because if
you want to create those clusters of
industry where you're attracting talent
from across the world and being
particularly appetizing so everyone
doesn't just go into the london
southeast bucket which is what's
happened for much skilled migration i
think over recent decades that's
definitely worth exploring but of course
as well you get many practical
situations about that in terms of how
you implement it how that feeds into the
whole uk's migration policy too and of
course the danger of going down that
route is you do end up with a wholly
planned economy which will go and say
this is going to happen here we're going
to have this many people and i think you
know we've tried to plan the economy in
various times of our recent history and
it hasn't always been wholly successful
but i think the crucial point which
you're right trevor is you've got to
have the ability for each region to do
things differently and to have the
powers to do that so whether it's
getting more visas for particular
aspects of their labor markets having
control over taxes being able to maybe
do something around corporation tax or
business rates within different areas
because
that's the only way you break this cycle
that we've had and i think there was a
change made it's a very technical thing
it's a very important thing the treasury
has this thing called the green book
which defines where government
investment goes and rishi sunak ripped
up the green book and rewrote it last
year that was one most important things
because that's become the cyclical thing
which is where do you want to invest
where you're going to get the highest
rate of return where is that london the
southeast and that's how you've got the
situation of the overheated economy
within the south and that's now being
redone to put an um and influence on
other aspects not just your direct
financial return of investment so that's
the kind of thing i think you need to
look up but i think definitely visas for
particular regions i think that's that's
something that the man should definitely
lobby for charles what do you think uh
leeds being able to control its labour
market
i think there's so much to be said
around
the point seven has made
one thing is clear the regions the
cities the towns and the businesses in
those localities are best able to
identify the skills they need
they're also able to identify the
matching of skills to jobs whether it's
high skills and low skills i'd wanted to
intervene in the last question about the
low skills and and the low jobs and why
we are where we are very very um
complicated and complex but nonetheless
i think there's something to be said
about giving um a kind of real autonomy
to the regions to decide what they want
for their businesses for the individuals
for the regions and the cities but i
think there's complication around
managing the wider concept
administratively and logistically around
um
the issue of immigration and we need to
handle that with care
empowerment but i think there's also got
to be that cross-regional collaboration
as well because otherwise you're
reinvented wheels so i think it's the
power in that coming together
um
we've heard mentioned several times in
this discussion the leveling up white
paper uh for which
you know there are millions sitting
waiting uh rather like you know waiting
for the new harry potter or whatever it
is um
i'm going to ask each one of you to tell
me
something that you really want to see in
that white paper
you know whether it is a number
of money or it is a sentence or it is a
policy hesseltine saying
you know uh have accountable leaders in
every place and that would be the thing
that made difference so each one of you
start with you chris
if you if if the prime minister rang you
up and said chris you've got a paragraph
and
you can write it and nobody can
interfere with it what would it be
what i would have is a commitment to
nuclear energy we need reliable uh cheap
energy the northwest of england has a
huge nuclear sector huge amounts of
talent in the northwest of england so i
want to see that because i believe the
north of england and part of the
leveling a significant part of our
leveling up ought to be manufacturing
including heavy manufacturing
and therefore we need reliable energy
that doesn't go out every time uh the
wind stops blowing so nuclear energy is
good for industry and it's going to be
good for the northwest
investment in our young people
investment in uh ensuring that they
we can
trump all form of fear that young people
have right now about what their future
is and makes that they can thrive and
grow their career in the north and seats
at the table for
female female-led businesses black age
minority-led businesses and young people
when these big decisions are being made
and a i can give you the bank details
for a bank account for that to be paid
into
yeah well um you can find that on the
website
okay charles trevor you'll expect me to
say real investment in skills and jobs
and in the potential of the young ones
and i think the university sector the
higher education sector and the further
education sector really really play a
role in trying to build this skilled
base that the smes and large
organizations need
research and development there needs to
be funding in that and i think they need
to be funding in the relationship
between businesses and the academic
sector
i want to see a very clear plan of
delivery about how all these changes are
going to be made because it's so easy
for politicians to talk about improving
life chances and proving town centres
improving infrastructure but what we are
talking about is hundreds if not
thousands of tiny projects all across
the country which on the whole will
level up and i think essentially you
need to see a way to actually do that
because for me to successfully level up
is as big of a challenge to the british
state as brexit and we know that took a
long time and a lot of effort so i want
clear detail plan and accountability
data metrics what does success look like
okay we've got a a couple of minutes and
i just want to um
ask just a question of my my own one of
the things that i'm very struck by and
seb's book really
without wanting to plug it uh
illustrates this rather brilliantly
um the big change that's come come about
has been in what you might call company
towns i started life as a chemist and
they might have sent me to middlesbrough
and so on and but you know these are
towns which are built on a single
industry obviously it's sometimes in a
single
company and to some extent all that's
been destroyed and i just want to give
each one of you quickly 10 seconds
what do we do about towns which have
lost their original
purpose i mean
it's a cultural thing as well said
when i went to wakefield which i think
is a very key example of one of those
places which was a male and mining place
it's found a new cultural identity
through art and culture through the
hepworth gallery the yorkshire sculpture
park and all different towns i think are
quite good at doing that but you've got
to have good transport links they can
get and link into those nearby other
towns and other cities as well because i
think if they're just left on their own
without the ability to have links to
their nearby region then they will feel
a bit down i can only have one sim on
quickly i think it's about learning from
other other cities or the other
communities that are built forward
better
and involve the community and their
decision making
okay sorry charles sorry chris
but that's it for this discussion part
of our big ideas live on sky news uh in
a moment
well hello again everyone uh it's been
an arduous uh day so uh thank you for uh
sticking with us your fortitude and uh
and perseverance has been uh hopefully
rewarded by some fascinating insights
this is actually the last session of the
day now i don't know what the collective
term for a group of uh sky news
presenters is a sort of a launch of
presenters uh
perhaps but hopefully uh
no introduction required now on my far
left ed conway our data and economics
editor samantha washington
my fellow presenter trevor phillips my
fellow presenter we're here really to
sort of chew over what we've uh picked
up over the course of the day but before
we do this i was guys uh
i don't know whether it still is our
slogan first with breaking news always
used to be didn't it but we do have some
breaking news which uh ed can uh
talk to us about which is that so we've
had the latest world economic outlook
from the imf in the last hour or so so
ed what are the highlights yeah normally
this time of year i would be in
washington but i have chosen rotherham
over washington dc
um and i think that was the right choice
definitely but so the imf are having
their their annual meeting at the moment
and um they've just brought out their
world economic outlook so so this is
their kind of
their they do every six months their
opportunity to look at the state of the
global economy and that's what what's
interesting and it kind of feeds into i
think stuff on on all of our sessions is
they've cut their global growth forecast
and they've done it partly in the face
of what we've been talking about you
know the supply chain uh crunch that
we're all facing they've raised their
inflation forecast and a lot of people
are looking at and saying you know is
that a kind of a bit of a stagflation
warning i mean i i don't know if i'd go
quite that far but but nonetheless lower
growth higher inflation um and
it goes back to this point that you know
that
we are in this kind of very difficult
moment at the moment it to some extent
you know there's a good news story
behind it which is that you've got the
global economy growing at the fastest
rate that we have ever seen you know in
the post-war era we we're just not used
to that the machine is not just not used
to six percent growth which is kind of
what we've got in in the uk and the u.s
and in loads of other places but as a
result of that the whole machine that
underlies it is really struggling to
keep up and then you have kind of this
energy price shock and you've got all of
the other things interacting so the
imf's kind of put their tuppence in and
they they you know they are officially
concerned uh which i imagine is a story
that we're going to be kind of talking
about for the next uh few days at least
absolutely i mean one of the big themes
for me that's come out of today and sam
certainly when you were talking to mark
carney it came out in spades which is
the rising cost
of the transition away from fossil fuels
that pivot towards net zero that the
cost is becoming ever clearer and i
wonder whether the authorities are
actually being honest with publics about
that around the world well i think
there's a lot of debate about to what
extent the government needs to be
subsidizing this to what extent uh
individuals are going to be responsible
but i thought one of the really
interesting things that came out of
talking to the former governor of the
bank of england
was the uh the delta in the amount of
investment now going into uh on
companies balance sheets towards net
zero goals so he was talking about back
in paris
less than a third of countries that were
there had net zero commitments and after
that that's gone up now to three
quarters
of countries but cascading down from
governments getting involved as has been
corporates also uh getting involved in
in green recovery and investing in green
infrastructure and he said that that
corresponding number had gone from five
trillion invested on companies balance
sheets up to 90 trillion of course
there's still a lot of challenges
because 90 trillion is an awful lot of
money but we need hundreds of trillions
to invest in in green infrastructure
some of the sectors are already
profitable i think solar and wind and
you can see what's happened with the
electric car
industry as well you know that you have
the electric car companies that are
worth more than a lot of the other uh
top car companies combined but it's
getting that money which is out there
isn't it ed i mean that's the size of
the global savings glut that we need to
somehow incentivize to get into these
green sectors some of which are not yet
profitable and it's about getting that
right combination of government support
uh corporate finance getting all those
incentives aligned to get the money
where it needs to be it is i mean the
world is a wash with liquidity but at
the same time with so many people
chasing these assets there's going to be
asset price inflation and you're already
seeing it in the elevated prices that
the likes of bp and shell are paying for
example to develop offshore wind farms i
think you know what's interesting
is that it feels real
you know
all of us have been to kind of
conferences you know perhaps like this
one or others where people have talked
very boldly about what they're going to
do about net zero or about kind of
greenifying their processes
but in the last kind of three or four
years it's just started to feel more
real hasn't it and that's kind of what
what mark carney was kind of talking
about that that has turned into real
money now extended to real commitments
but what's interesting like you're
saying is
the
the fact that it's very easy to make
bold promises it's very easy to you know
be a cop and make a promise about about
something that you haven't necessarily
got a kind of strict plan for like sam
was
was quizzing mark connie about
but when that becomes real and you
actually have to implement it and it
leads to higher inflation it leads to
higher energy costs
then things can get crunchy and and i
feel like we're kind of getting to that
crunchy stage now yeah you know solar
solar is much cheaper now why is it
cheaper it's cheaper partly because
we've got better at making solar panels
but it's cheaper partly because
most of these solar panels are made in
china
and what is powering that process coal
and coal is very cheap and now suddenly
china is deciding you know whether it's
actually going to start using actually
be using as much coal as it was before
and suddenly
solar might not look quite so cheap in
the future so you know this is this is
where
it gets interesting i say you know in
italics because i think
the next few decades are going to be
more crunchy when it comes to uh to the
to the net zero debate and
and it's going to affect all of our
lives in a way that i you know it hasn't
before and i imagine you know the public
and many of your businesses
are now actually thinking
this this this is something we need to
think very seriously about it's real
yeah can i add to that because i think
credibility is going to be so important
to get the money flowing to where it
needs to be you have to accept that
government policy is credible that their
commitments are credible one of the
things i was pushing mark carney about
is is the uk government credible on its
own net zero commitments why are we even
considering investing in a coal mine in
gas and oil exploration in cambo sands
and he gave quite a politician's answer
to it didn't he but but i think
in essence what he was saying is at
least there's an inquiry they haven't
just gone ahead with it and when you do
the inquiry you have to look at the cost
and benefits of it which might not sound
very satisfactory because you know there
is another answer which is just say no
but actually if you do the inquiry and
you're exposing the fact that there
won't be any more need for what comes
out of this coal mine from 2035 then you
start to think
you know the financial institutions
won't be investing in these things if
they think that it's going to be a
product that doesn't have lifespan
anymore you need cooking see the thing
is you need coking coal for solar panels
that's you know again there's the
complexity that
i don't know if government has actually
fully comprehended that but you need
coke and coal not just to make it the
frog understanding yeah i don't think
the frog has got that one either but i
mean i think he's slightly further ahead
than some politicians dare i say but
it's not you know the green transition
involves
creating you know creating a lot of
carbon and that's that's the paradox
that i don't think has been fully
explained to you know to the general
public and and maybe even to the
politicians as well and that's why
you know he gave a politician's answer
but i think until
that has you know
has been properly explained about what
the trade-offs of saying no to i mean
i don't think it's easy i genuinely
don't think it's easy the sort of
mechanisms you need in that transition
period are things like carbon offsetting
and then you get into the arguments well
you're just allowing people to pay their
way out of their emissions but you need
to get from a to b so there has to be a
way to it yeah i mean trevor you grow
politicians every every week
do you ever get the sense that
there could be more honesty from them
about the cost of the transition
well i think there could be more honesty
if i thought they knew what they were
doing
actually um
people can only be as honest as they
know
and i i i do
think unfortunately that
in politics
exactly as ed was just saying
we haven't really started to have a
proper conversation
about what many of these things mean so
for example
one thing that surprises me is that
politics isn't talking about what
i don't know if it is but it could be an
esg
bubble i mean there is
that 90 trillion is going somewhere
but it's going more it's tracking um
it's marching
in uh pursuit of assets where things are
promised now the big the big example
there is fintech where you know people
who haven't made a profit and show no
signs of making a profit are being
valued at five billion dollars and but i
think that is also true
to some extent in terms of quote-unquote
green assets that there's
chunks of money going
in places where
there might be the promise but actually
nobody really knows
and the second thing is i think sam's
point very very important
it's going to be
harder before it gets easier
there's going to have to be
if any of these technologies is
successful there's going to be a load of
money chucked into it
before
anything comes out to the other end i
mean the one the example we have for
example for us we've spent gigantic sums
on nuclear
and actually we we sort of knew what
would happen with nuclear that
eventually it would pay off but even now
what uh
60 70 years on from
uh the size will be in all that
it's only just starting to wash its face
so i think there's a big problem
that politics basically
is not
equipped to deal with
because
when i talk to politicians um
you know
there's no point me talking to them
about
what will it look like in 2050 because
most of the time they can't even see
what what it's going to look like at 20
50 tonight they're just going into the
election
yeah they're thinking in five-year
cycles rather than 50-year ones
yeah
i mean one of the points that you tried
to tease out of mark carney was whether
the uk was set is setting the right
example as we approach cop 26.
yeah i mean the uk government's been
criticized by its own independent
climate change committee as i'm sure
many of you know
for not having really a detailed plan we
don't know you know what what the road
map is to get to net zero we don't know
what it's going to cost and we're also
hearing a lot about the tensions with
treasury about is is treasury going to
stump up
for this when we've got covert to pay
for and
um
and all the rest of it so
just remind me of sorry i'm somebody was
talking to me in my ear and i lost track
of what i was saying
no i was just saying what did what did
you get make of his answer then when you
tried to tease that out of him
um
tease it out of him about the he was
quite a politician wasn't it oh yeah
yeah yeah i mean
but he is he's a great politician what i
thought was interesting though is i
didn't get much out of him on that
because it was all very policy based and
you know you could give me one of his
rehearsed answers but when i was asking
him about
basically the style point which was you
know the way the prime minister frames
the language around this i mean he
references kermit the frog about it's
not easy being green and he's talking
about bunny huggers uh is that helpful
and he sort of smirked didn't any it was
more what he didn't say um
when i asked him is that language that
that you would use and he said no
and he's obviously probably one of the
people in the world taking climate the
most seriously so i i think you can
deduce
what you may i think you've got more of
it out of him i you know i'm used to i i
it's someone i've both interviewed mark
carney before and we're both talking
about this backstage sometimes you know
sometimes he's quite tough to get stuff
out of but i felt actually what you saw
there was quite a good mark carney
interview where he did actually go a
little bit further than he usually does
um and you know i think both on you know
the the coal mine he talks slightly kind
of more freely about that than i
expected also about energy bills for for
households and businesses in in this
country
and again it comes down to the facts
that a lot of this stuff is no longer
academic i think that's this isn't it
this this is becoming real it's real for
for many of your kind of executive
decisions it's real for many households
as well
and it's you can't avoid it you can't
just talk in kind of generalities
anymore about this which makes it more
tangible for us as as a news
organization but also for
for the country
we haven't got an awful lot of time left
but before we do trevor if i can put
this politely you probably you have more
miles on the clock than uh
the the rest of us
we've we've had this sort of younger
than you
certainly in uh spirit um yeah it's it's
a drug zone it helps
i mean we've just gone through this
period where we've had queues at petrol
stations
the talk is of inflation of stagflation
there's there's more than a sort of
whiff of the 1970s
about this as someone who's around in
the late 1970s i mean
i mean i was there too but i was only at
school i hated to add i mean
do you do you think the comparison is
going to get into many knots
[Laughter]
do you think these comparisons with the
late 70s are being overdone
uh i don't think they're being overdone
but i think they might be um
might mislead us um
in in summary i mean i i interviewed
michael hesseltown who was a minister
and that's 73 when we had three day week
and all that um
and i was saying to him that i was a
student at the time and they locked us
out of the laboratory because
you know we we're just using
we didn't have the the power um to to do
the work that we're supposed to do and
if i had to go to the
library
i mean no student goes to the library in
daylight for god's sake i mean you'd
have to have a candle
happily i didn't go to the library ever
so it doesn't matter but the point is
that
i think what we were seeing there was
the end of something
the disruption was we could see the end
of primary industries coal and so on
coming
um didn't know what was coming next but
that was all about the end of something
and how
we managed that process today i think
what we're talking about is the
beginning of something and we just don't
quite know how that's going to work it
struck me in the the the fight the panel
that i was doing
is thinking about it uh simone rush
made it used a good example of a digital
company that's succeeding in lead and it
struck me
what we're talking about now is a
destruction to some extent of geography
now the north used to be the north
because of coal
and salt uh and iron and ports
now
in a world where those things have gone
frankly those industries gone somewhere
else and what we're doing now is what
hugh's talking about in leeds
the geography is destroyed
one of the things i'm just wondering is
if we've
slightly killed ourselves
the whole today that there is going to
be something separate called the north
and whether what separates us is not
going to be
the primary you know economics and so on
but just whether you
how you say the word
the word for the thing that you get into
when you really want to wash your whole
body i'm trying not to say it begins
with b
bath
yes
or bath
perfectly good point and i mean the way
that uh
digital infrastructure is being rolled
out you know working from home
phenomenon is very much a part of that
isn't it yeah
but
that is basically all we've got time for
uh trevor sam ed thank you very much uh
that concludes today's event we've
really enjoyed being up here in this
absolutely astonishing building somewhat
chilly at times but uh hope hasn't been
too uncomfortable for the with the
heating on um thank you for engaging in
some fascinating discussions and for
being here and sharing your thoughts
with us in person and online we are
going to be back at some point very soon
with more big ideas live but in the
meantime thank you very much indeed for
company today
[Applause]
you